[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on everyone welcome back
thank you for uh your patience everybody
i had a little trouble getting the
stream going but you know we are live
right now and we're doing it doing it
big time what's going on everybody
thank you for joining me my name is
clinton jones i'm also known as the
punisher
and uh yeah today we're going to be
diving into
the creation of my alternate realities
submission obviously i can't win my own
challenge but you guys know there's a
challenge going on right now
um if you don't know about it definitely
there's a there's a video that i'll
point to in the screen that
i'll have to link to later um but check
it out
it's an incredible challenge we got
prizes from p and y
rococo um wacom
aftershocks and qixel and it's going out
to the uh
first uh for first second third fourth
and fifth place for all the renters but
i'm gonna be doing my renter today
on the stream at least starting it you
know so let me let me uh
show you guys let me give you guys a
brief little overview of what we're
gonna be doing today
on the stream if that sounds good to
y'all so let's uh let's let's hop in
here for a second
so i want to show you guys how i created
this piece of concept art that's going
to be guiding my eye
throughout the creation process of this
art and this is about i don't know 75 to
80
of what i'm seeing in my head i
certainly want to add
some robots and some plants you know
there's going to be some of that going
on here too
i'm not super happy with happy with the
left side of the world over here too
it's a little flat but i just want to
talk to you guys and show you how i
created this in photoshop
and why it's so important and super
necessary from there
you know we'll hop into the purif board
that i created
and i just want to show you guys how i'm
using this to you know
use as a reference throughout my
creation process i can zoom in here
and i want to show you guys some art
books that i've been using and pulling
images from
um that have inspired me that inspired
my render and how i got the idea for my
render
so i want to talk to you guys about that
as well um
i have some frames down here from some
of my favorite movies this is behind
enemy lines well owen wilson yes this is
owen wilson and uh children of men
there's an incredible scene in children
of men at the end towards the end of the
movie that's just absolutely insane
and i'm using this as like some
foreground and background
elements here you can obviously see this
like gate this falling gate
is right in the foreground it's just
helping me get a look that's going to
guide my eyes throughout the process
so um dave over there i see you thank
you for that super chat
um he says have some kombucha thank you
i got some in the fridge i'll bust it
out in a second
um also your concept art is similar to
my idea
dude no worries if uh if my concept art
is similar to your guys's idea
don't worry roll with your idea there
can be two or three or four or five or
ten post-apocalyptic renders
on this challenge don't copy what i'm
doing obviously
but roll with what you had in mind okay
we have until june first to deliver
these uh
these renders and i'm gonna put them
together for the most epic
uh basically the most epic montage the
internet has ever seen so
um before we hop into it y'all uh
i want to give a quick shout out to
today's
sponsor um they make these streams and
these videos and basically my full-time
job on this channel possible so
i'll be back in two minutes y'all hang
tight and i'll see you soon
stream is brought to you by our friends
over at skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
like you guys who are looking to up
their game
grow their value and learn a new skill
now it doesn't matter
if you're a beginner intermediate or
advanced on your journey
you can learn anything here on
skillshare at any level
so i want to do something a little
different this time around and tell you
guys three fun facts about myself
through different courses on skillshare
the first one is a drawing course by
brent evaston and it walks you through
all the basic steps of drawing all the
important
fundamental foundational building blocks
that you'll need if you want to get
started
when i was in middle school i always
took art as an elective and i still draw
today i love drawing in pencil and pen
and it's a great way for me to get out
of my head and just get creative
on paper as opposed to behind a computer
monitor
the second course is a yoga course and
the reason i'm doing a yoga course is
because i'm actually
a certified yoga instructor now i don't
teach classes regularly but i love yoga
so much
that i wanted to learn as much as
possible and took a yoga teacher
training class
and truly believe that yoga is the key
to your youth
and i think it's super important that us
3d artists get into yoga because
we're sitting down all the time you know
i'm live streaming all the time we got
to get up we got to get healthy
and we got to stretch our bodies so this
course by deep kumar is a really nice
class
and it goes to all the basic poses that
you guys will need to start building
your yoga foundation and finally i
love drumming so much
i started in drumline in eighth grade
and just
love making some beats so if you guys
want to learn to make some beats
then check out this course by thomas
george it's an ableton live
10 course so this is a 10 hour and 24
minute course
definitely a deep dive into making music
in ableton live 10. but if you guys want
something smaller i guarantee you you
can search it up here
on skillshare and you'll find exactly
what you're looking for so as a
skillshare member you guys get unlimited
access to regularly updated premium
content
for less than 9.99 a month for a yearly
subscription and to the first thousand
people who click the link in the
description
i got you guys with a free trial of a
skillshare premium
membership you guys are gonna learn
something new you're gonna grow
you're gonna get past the competition
and it also helps me out too it helps me
do more of these live streams so click
the link in the description and start
learning
all right thanks y'all appreciate you
thank you for your patience thank you
for your time
um yeah skillshare is rate if you want
to learn more stuff
then yeah click the link below get that
uh get those
get that free that free trial um
so guys let's jump in all right i want
to show y'all
well let's just jump into it there's so
much to do um okay let's see
here we go here we go bam all right so
if you guys are just joining us we're
gonna talk i'm gonna talk to you about
how i started uh
the creation of this little concept art
piece it's nothing fancy
i am no concept artist and i am no
photoshop master
that is that is a just a fact all right
but this is going to help me you know
throughout my creation process
so let's hop into photoshop real quick
and i want to show you guys how i
created this
um so let's see here let's turn off all
these layers
and let's start with the reference so
if you guys are joining me on this
challenge the alternate realities
challenge
you have downloaded the folder um
with all the project files and you'll
get something looking like this
you got a person and you got a sphere
and your job
is to fill out this environment
you know this is my version of it
keeping the person and the sphere
in frame and there's probably a little
bit of stuff you know obscuring the
front of this and like maybe there's a
little bit of stuff obscuring the sphere
up here just a bit but
notice how the character and the sphere
its visual weight is maintained
all right you know on off on off you
guys get the point right
so let's build this thing up how am i
doing this so we'll start with the
foreground
um and i'm just taking all those
different little pieces here
from uh from that purif board that i
have
these are all the little pieces i'm
using this stuff as the foreground
and i'm using this stuff as uh the
character here
from from uh what is it uh
behind enemy lines one of my favorites
one of my all-time favorite movies
so i'm just pulling some foreground
stuff and one tip here is
instead of erasing the
you know the actual layer here i'm
actually using an adjustment layer
so this little this little guy right
here and a vector mask right and you can
paint black and white
onto this vector mask and remove
different parts of the image
just by painting black and white so it's
like an eraser
but you can actually paint things back
in if you realize like oh i want to get
this out of the way
but oh no i actually want to switch it
up so i'll switch my brush to a white
brush
and i'll paint it back in so you're
working non-destructively
and i'm just kind of building up these
layers to match you know i added like a
wet street from
i think this is from fury a behind the
scenes shot of uh
from fury the brad pitt tank movie
um so that's my foreground my background
let's take a look at my background so
this is my buildings my buildings layer
let's go ahead and just like
turn all these off and work up one by
one so
i'm pulling just different images from
google and
kind of dropping them in to shape out
this sphere
right so i'm going to work with the
negative space
and it's really you know it's just i'm
using it i'm using the reference here as
a guide which is
exactly what you guys should be doing if
you're joining me on this challenge
um gg thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you very much you send in
love and some some apple bucks
thanks for all the knowledge apple bucks
map
maple maple bucks that good maple syrup
thank you for the maple syrup money i
appreciate you
i actually just ran out a few days ago
all right so
um to finish it up yeah this is just
another image here um this is from
an island called battleship island uh
also known as hashima
off the coast of japan and it was an old
either
coal mining town or an oil town or
something
and they closed it down i think in the
60s i'm not really sure
and i want to show you guys some art
books um right after this
and then right here so i'm just doing a
little brightness and contrast on that
to
kind of even things out now to pull the
character out from the background
actually i'll save that for last i'm
just dropping in the background here you
know this is just your classic uh
foggy field render and it's just a
placeholder you know i'll probably put
something else back there when i
actually do the render
but um it's just a it's a good little
placeholder
and what else what else since i'm lazy i
just turned things black and white
because i'd rather not
color correct and composite and i'll
just get my tones correct in a black and
white version
and you can see the difference here i
kind of crunched it up a little bit
and i added some fog which is just
another another layer here
large white soft brush low opacity kind
of getting back here behind owen wilson
and uh popping them out from the
background just a little bit
larry bryant thank you for the super
chat i see you
get my masters in vfx and you're
inspiring me to keep going when times
are tough thanks for what you do
absolutely man good luck on that learn
as much as you can
put it to good use make some cool stuff
and uh thanks for hanging out with me on
the stream here man i appreciate it
thank you for the support so yeah the
reason i'm doing in black and white is
just
the color you know the color is going to
happen in the program when i do it in
the vfx and when i do it in the freaking
cg world it's going to happen all right
the colors the color will be there
black and white is just easier for me to
do it here in photoshop
so i don't have to focus on color this
is just a quick and dirty thing to get
my idea out you know what i mean
bar oh boy bart low mage does deck
um apologies if i butchered that man uh
thank you for the super chat he says hey
clint love your content
and taking part in the challenges um
it's off topic but what are those
glasses been looking for frames like
these forever oh you talking about these
cult leader glasses the ones that
again everyone calls them cult leader
glasses dude
ah it's from that freaking far car game
um so yeah no these are i just get my
stuff from zenny
it's any optical um it's a really cheap
and easy way to get some glasses
yeah just get your prescription go over
there get your glasses
um but thanks for the super chat i
appreciate you
now i want to talk to you guys about
ideas here
um how did i get the idea for this
render and i also be curious to know how
you guys got the idea for your renders
i'll show you my process so here's what
i do i have a bunch of art books right
here as you can see
um this is just a fraction of the art
books i have
i got a whole bunch back here as you
guys can probably see the bookshelf
and i love art books because they really
help me get creative
and it's a physical thing that i can
flip through the pages and and really
get inspired so this one here
i took the cover off because it's kind
of an expensive art book it's
these things can get a little pricey and
i don't i didn't want to damage it so
it's called um
city of darkness revisited and this is
an incredible art book man check check
this out
it's got like all of uh
well there's a place called the walled
kowloon city in hong kong
it was on the kowloon side hence the
name and it was
torn down in 1995 and was actually the
densest place
the densest human population in the
whole world um
if what is what's the fact if uh
if hong kong in 2001 had 25 people
then the walled city in 1993 had 605
people
it's ridiculous but this book as you can
see you know like
by the images here you guys can see that
it definitely inspired the render
so i flipped through this thing and i
was like you know what are some cool
some cool things that i can get into
obviously you know batman they did some
batman stuff with it
this book is great it goes through the
history of the whole place and
um and it's just it's incredible because
it's just
a pile of apartments
and people and there was like dentist
shops butchers and it was a very crime
ridden place
but this book goes through and
interviews all the people there
it's a really cool one it's called city
of darkness
revisited now another one that i like
there's a photographer
well this actually isn't the same
photographer anyway this one's called
amazing construction zone
and uh there's one render in particular
or one image in particular that i loved
this one right here so let me see if i
can get
a closer view on that this is
um basically an underground tunnel
construction site and it looks freaking
sweet
yeah this whole book is full of this
stuff
lots of really inspiring renders or not
renders photography that i use
for my renders to get inspired
this stuff is amazing hoichi nishiyama
if you guys want to check that out on
amazon
amazing construction zone another art
book that
really inspired this render that i'm
going to be doing is
the tech on concrete uh graphic
like the art of tekken concrete which is
an anime
that's very detailed and these are all
just
incredible pencil drawings i forget the
artist's name but my god
are these incredible i just want to show
you
a couple more um there's one of like a
construction site
like man just this yeah look at that
look at this
it's so freaking cool um
lots of detail in these pencil drawings
here so these really blew my mind and
like
helped me come up with this render um
yeah more
just construction site stuff
you guys can't tell already i'm pretty
obsessed with construction sites
there's just a lot of texture and detail
that goes into all this stuff
um two more and then we'll get into it
this one
is a photo book of hashima battlefield
or battleship island
and it you know has a bunch of shots of
of the place and you know the history of
the place
and you know like the schools and
everything
some really cool art some really cool
photography of this place
and i think you could probably get this
on amazon too
um it's called what is this
it's all in japanese oh um
yeah just i don't know look up
battleship island or hashima
art book maybe it'll be on amazon and
finally my favorite game ever
well one of them hyper light drifter now
this is gonna
help me out with like a lot of the
robots and stuff um
and a lot of the characters when i get
into the character work
on this because i'm thinking the main
character is gonna be some sort of like
half
cyborg thing and um
you know it's gonna be carrying like a
box of
seeds or something and every step it
takes it'll grow
something i don't know we'll figure it
out but that's
that's what i do to get inspired as i go
through my art books
or you guys can go through pinterest or
you can get some art books
and i'll keep the ones that that that
really speak to me that are close to me
i don't buy every art book out there
they can get a little expensive but
yeah that's kind of how i get inspired i
also listen to music that like
that feels like the render that feels
like the tone that i want to be in so
that kind of got me this
you know this idea right up in here
all right so how the heck am i going to
start this thing i guess i'll open the
project file
let's see let's see let's see
um where would it even be i hadn't even
i had guys i hadn't even started this
thing yet
uh challenge announcement video
deliverables
3d templates c4d
here we go this is it so fun fact you
guys um
if you want to get rid of these bars in
c4d you can hit alt
v and you go to your safe frames and
just turn them off
and you'll you'll be set up to go but
this will this will at least help you
guys like see
you're not gonna have to worry about
that stuff you know no need to render
the stuff and place the stuff you're not
going to use
sam lemon thank you for the super chat
it says hey clint hope you're well
is it okay if the sphere is just a
background piece
and most of the focus is on the
character as long as the sphere
maintains most of its visual weight then
you are good to go
if you look at the first challenge we
did the parallel dimensions challenge
each render had a mountain in it and
some people
you know the goal was to keep the
mountain keep the mountain visible so
keep your sphere visible please
um you obviously
you know make it look cool make it look
however you want
um but just make sure it's still there
okay like that's that's really the whole
point that's the whole point
the character and the sphere are the
unifying elements that allow us to match
cut between every single render
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
but yeah
i have to figure out what the heck where
do we even start man
where do we even start so
let's see here i'm going to save the
character for last
i'm not even going to worry about the
character until last i think the first
thing i'll do
is probably get some sort of temp block
out
um of the buildings and the lighting
i want to get some temp lighting going
and i also
would like to maybe work on my
foreground and get started on my
foreground just a little bit and start
working that up
so that's probably what we're gonna do
today on the stream
if i can get to that point with some
temp lighting a block out of my
buildings
and um a ground plane
with some nice textures on it i'll feel
comfortable and i'll feel nice
guys we have till june 1st to submit
these renders so
if you're wrapping up your render spend
some more time on it
definitely you have a month and a half
i'm not going to rush this process
i'm not going to throw in stuff um
and say uh it's final just because it's
in there you know what i mean
i'm going to take this slow and i'm
really going to enjoy this i'm no
i'm in no rush to create something asap
i want to make sure that this is as good
as it can be so i'm going to spend the
time to make it detailed and make it
awesome and i hope that you guys
do the same um we got a couple more
super chats jesse what's up you said you
love watching the vids
they're relaxing and i keep them on my
second monitor while doing blender
projects dude that's what's up that's
what is
up man yeah keep it going um keep the
keep the live streams going i know
they're long they're very long sometimes
but keep them in the background
and you know i'm working off to the side
and you're working on your project
that's exactly what we're doing man
that's the whole point
of this that is the whole point and
johan thank you
says keep going but the corridor channel
hasn't been the same since you left man
oh i appreciate that
um yeah i don't know i was there
yesterday
we got we all got lunch together and
hung out and played some smash bros and
uh they showed me some cool stuff they
were working on man but yeah i
appreciate that
um i'll pop in from time to time
definitely pop in from time to time win
bush
win bush what up what up dude good to
see ya
you know i thought about doing this one
in unreal engine but i was like ooh
that'll be i'll be going off into no
man's land you know ooh that'd be a
tough one
but windbush dude i'm glad you're here
man it's always good to see you in the
chat man i appreciate you a lot
um let's frickin let's hop into it we're
all just hanging out today guys this is
a good time i hope you all are working
on your renders having a good time
so like i said i'm saving the character
for last
um one thing that i want to keep in mind
too is like
my memory my ram my visual performance
you know like my computer's
life's life source i don't want it
crunching up on me
i do have an nvidia rtx uh quadro 6000
up in here
which has 24 gigabytes of vram it's a
lot of vram
but i don't wanna just throw everything
at it okay we have to be
we have to be selective about all the
crap we throw in our scene
so i'm gonna do the character last
that's what i did on the last one
and hopefully we can you know we can uh
make something nice with that let's
start with the block out all right
enough chat enough chit chat
let's do it so bam cube let's
hop out of the camera
cool cool and let's start building out
our scene yeah
so let's see
i'm gonna create what i have in
my concept art first and then i'll start
mixing things up i want to ensure that
the 3d scene generally
works and feels right and then we'll
start soloing and going from there so
let me get my safe frames back
it's alt v get your save frames back
let's pull up
our our reference
we don't need to render anything right
now so i'm just going to pop my
reference right up
in here and let's see
let's see let's get this guy bam i wish
there was like a hotkey
in pure f to like snap to
the the picture you have selected anyway
um
sai sharon good to see you again thank
you for the super chat you're excited to
see the result dude me too
this is my most ambitious render yet so
we'll see
how this goes i'm excited for i'm very
excited for i can't wait to do sound
design and music and
everything that's gonna be good um and
superior products
or superior productions uh thank you for
the super chat you're saying can the
sphere be animated in place
or should it be stationary dude i will
say it again
i don't care what y'all do as long as it
maintains its visual weight
as long as it maintains its its
size and its influence on the render
then you can do whatever you want you
can animate it as long as it stays in
place i don't care
yeah all this stuff is in the faqs um
definitely be sure to read that guys
there's a lot of questions coming in
definitely a lot of questions coming in
let's get these safe frames
uh let's get the opacity down to like 50
so we can still see through here all
right
mr owen wilson all right let's get you
right up in here
okay okay we can make this sphere
editable
crunch it down a little bit
bam i'll just have it extend just past
the safe frame so we can
see what's going on something like that
okay um kl
that's your loop cut tool you know go in
edge mode get that going
bam make the slice hop in here select
that face
d for extrude and just move it out there
now this will now i'm getting into it
like this is what i'm thinking about so
many things i'm thinking about
how far i need to extrude this because
it will affect our lighting but that's
like that's some way forward thinking
right now
and it's not necessary so i'm just going
to extrude it past the frame we can
always add and shape the light later
okay
next we got some we got a series of
buildings kind of going off into the
background here so here's what i'm gonna
do
for this nb will pull up
your wireframe view let's go ahead and
grab a cube
and let's make a series of buildings
with a cloner so i'm just going to hit
c we'll make it editable um we'll scale
this
up i think i changed control 1 2 3
did i go 1 2 3 how did i you guys are
probably saying what am i why am i
saying one two three
shift one two three uh i thought i'd
set these hotkeys uh
never mind i'll figure that out later t
for scale
let's scale it up these are gonna be
some tall skinny buildings something
like that
very cool very cool let's take this and
let's move the anchor point
down so i'm gonna grab my
the axis center tool we'll drop the y
all the way to the bottom and execute so
that way when we scale it up it scales
up from the bottom
just like that and i'm going to throw
this into a cloner so let's
hold alt drop it on the cloner there
it's doing a grid array by default and i
think we can go linear
and by default again the y is set to 50.
so they're getting sent up we don't want
that we want them sent
back so let's do x positive x
something like that yeah
cool and we can do like i don't know six
of them or something now let's throw a
randomizer in here this is where it gets
nice right
so let's do the if you have the cloner
selected by default it'll go
right into the effectors it's pretty
sweet so select your cloner
and let's hold down that cloner button
there and let's go to the random
effector
and you can see it's already in there if
you had it selected
and the random effector is going to
randomly kind of distribute our stuff so
we want to move this a little bit you
know move this a little bit it's a large
scene
oh all right let's save our stuff here's
the thing here's the thing guys
don't save over the original project
file make a new project file
so that you have that backup just in
case um
let's see this would be c4d
and we'll call this alternate realities
underscore
i don't know 001 i guess
and when i'm finished with this render
you guys probably saw um
the the art breakdown i did of
the car on the ocean right
and i want to do another one of those
breakdowns for this as well
you guys really liked it there was some
storytelling it was chill it was moody
um the work was good and you guys liked
it it was short no one has time for this
no one has time for these streams man
these streams are long so i want to do
another one of those basically a
breakdown for every piece of art i do
i want to do it in that style so that'll
be fun
okay moving on let's hop back into our
camera and see what this is looking like
so you can see how it's kind of like
i wanted to i wanted to ride the edge of
this sphere
and we're kind of close we're certainly
kind of close let's let's
see if we hit play now we really need to
push
that back if we want
there to be zero parallax there's going
to be a little bit of parallax but we
really need to push that back into 3d
space if we
want this if we want this to be
maintained so we got to get smart with
it okay
definitely got to get smart with it zai
al
barakati i hope i didn't butcher that
but thank you
sir for the super chat very very
generous of you
my goodness thank you sir
um no text necessary just straight up
with the super chat man very cool
i really appreciate the support you guys
support helps me do this
um consistently it helps out a lot
all right so how are we going to do this
you know we want to taper them we want
to taper these
we can cheat it you know we can totally
cheat it let's try um
[Music]
how are we gonna do this how are we
gonna do this
i'm just gonna mess around until i get
the answer um i wanna offset the
end point like this guy
you see how i'm doing this i kind of
want to offset that and i think that is
just
from here we go yeah there we go so i'm
just moving the z
negative z so it kind of like tapers in
a little bit
and we can totally like i don't know
how this would work but we can animate
this
so we go to the last frame and we
animate it
like that which might look a little
funky
but it also might look kind of cool too
oh it wait it didn't animate
bam get that keyframe in there go to the
end
get this keyframe in there boom
and then that should be good to go yeah
there we go
so you can see how the buildings are
kind of moving and revealing
and sticking to the edge of this like
that could be an interesting effect i
never even thought about that but it's
like
the world is shifting around the
character kind of reminds me a little
bit of uh
dang yeah you know you guys know if you
know if you know you know
i'm not the biggest marvel movie guy um
but
doctor strange dude that freaking crazy
the visuals in that movie are insane
this kind of reminds me a little bit
that a little bit of that like shifting
and moving perspective which could be
sweet
you know like this character has
influence over the environment maybe
that's something who knows
who knows that's real cheating right
there yeah you said it right
siloam exactly that's some real cheating
right there dude
you gotta get crafty with it all right
cool
um let's work the random
rotation a little bit just a little bit
of something a little bit a
little a little bit a little bit of that
um henrik respect brother appreciate you
thank you for the super chat sir um very
generous of you as well
thank you thank you thank you um really
they do this does help guys it does help
i'm doing this full time now um you know
the
the brand deals the the skill shares and
your guys's super chats really helped me
pay
my bills pay the rent and all that stuff
so
it's much appreciated now let's do a
little
scale action on this thing let's let's
check the scale let's go up on the y
a little bit a little bit a little bit
of that
all right uniform scale so uniform scale
is going to get it
all together i don't want that i don't
want that oh what happened
i could i cut it i didn't i meant to
undo it
we got to put it back put it back where
it
belongs
all right so uncheck uniform scale we
don't want that poggy thank you for the
super chat
cheers from slovakia very cool very cool
i love traveling maybe i make out there
one day
fun fact slovakia is really small
i didn't know that how small
like as small as like new york
i don't know i usually know places
geography um
when i visit it so japan i know where
japan is
okay i know where taiwan is
um i know some other places too
but slovakia i've never been so i don't
know render rides
thank you uh love the super chat you
love the streams
good times man thank you so much really
appreciate it
okay so i'm just messing around with
that little animation there we probably
need to get a bigger building back there
a couple bigger buildings so here let's
hop out of this and let's see if we
can't
place some larger buildings back here so
i'm going to duplicate our
cloner control drag
and we can shift f3 this to bring up our
dope sheet
and we can delete the keyframes on our
cloner one we don't need to be
animating anything there so delete those
we can make these guys let's
let's make them hitting t we can scale
them up
and we can also let's see
we don't need as many so we can take it
down to three
and we'll push we'll push this back a
little bit
the further back in 3d space your
objects the
the um the less they will appear to move
in your frame okay
so we're really going to need to get
these things back there
maybe it can be revealed so these guys
are revealed
um let's move them what's the best way
to do this yeah i guess we can just
slide them over
we need them taller we need them taller
so i'm going to hit
t scale this up like this
and
maybe push them way back
so you see see how this is working here
now we probably will animate this one
too let's push these guys way back
um these two right here i'm going to hop
out of my camera view
and i'm really going to crank these guys
i'm going to do that by
just taking this this value here
holding if you hold shift these numbers
will move a lot faster
so i'm just kind of cranking it back and
it's almost at the sphere
it's basically at the sphere right now
the sphere is really back there
and you'll notice the sphere is parented
to the camera if i were to take the
sphere
out of the camera you'll see the sphere
move too
like nothing is nothing is safe from
parallax
you know what i mean you can see it if
you look right here
you can see the sphere uh appears to be
moving
obviously it's not moving because it's
the camera that's moving
but that's why it's parented uh into the
camera is so the sphere stays in one
place
so we can get that perfect loop you know
what i mean so
let's grab that cloner and those
yeah maybe that's too far back so let's
let's rope it in a little bit
there you go you see it just peeking in
there we go that's what we want
and i'll take that cloner and let's go
ahead and animate
this z here let's go forward
and we just want to like hug them up
against or maybe it's just the
positioning
maybe it's just the position so we'll
take that cloner
and coordinates bam
we'll move it up here and
lock it in right there bam cool so now
it's like all moving with
the camera
and to save on render space let's let's
grab both these cloners and set it to a
multi-instance
uh maybe a render instance yeah it
should be the same multi-instance render
instance it'll probably do the same deal
i don't know why i'm chugging already
i shouldn't be chugging already but i am
who knows this is all placeholder stuff
but you guys can see how like
we're maintaining the sphere's visual
weight right that makes sense we're
maintaining that uh
that background there this shape
so let's keep going let's keep going
with it let's save our stuff
this is our block out version now i kind
of want to work it up on the side too so
here's what i'll do
i will copy this one here
ctrl drag it over and let's kinda yeah
you see right there you see how that's
bam
so that looks good that shape right
there generally looks nice
okay so let's go back to frame
one we can move it
right there we'll lock that keyframe and
then i also want to adjust
the z here
bam so something like that bam and let's
see what that looks like
we'll scrub it
all right so it's kind of clipping i
think um
i can probably like this one feels good
but the end frame feels
it feels a little a little far out so
let's
find what axis that is yeah let's
set a keyframe here move it back and set
another keyframe and y'all you know
we're cheating
you see like there's a little bit of
parallax right there
feels kind of cool and it's subtle you
know when you play it
it's going to be a subtle situation
i don't know why why is it
chugging like it is shouldn't be
and we can select uh we can select all
frames or no un
deselect all frames i learned this one
from uh oh shoot what's his name
god dang i forget i'll remember
eventually
yeah uncheck all frames and then you'll
get your full frame rate basically
you'll get the real time speed of how
everything works
um barakati
thank you again for the very generous
super chat
he says thank you so much your channel
motivated my vfx journey how would you
go about learning c4d from barely
um on basics to decent specifically for
vfx and working with live action footage
okay so
i have a couple um tutorials
it's called a full vfx workflow and the
thumbnail is
a uh like a like a little newspaper
stand
watch that video it's about an hour long
and it just takes you through click by
click the whole process
bringing footage in tracking it dropping
your stuff in i also have another video
it's a
how to turn yourself into a robot the
thumbnail is me in a rococo
mocap suit with a robot watch that one
too
it has you know the full breakdown click
by click step by step
on how to do that too and it's the same
deal it's like how to use mocap suit
and how to shoot your footage track your
footage all that good stuff
so check those two out those are really
good ones other than that man like
i don't know grayscale gorilla is
amazing i i use them all the time
even video copilot even though it's
after effects they have some c4d stuff
too
um yeah and just just youtube your stuff
around skillshare hey
go to skillshare click the link in the
description get the the free
the free trial uh check it out they got
a lot of stuff too
so there's lots of options lots of
options
all right so you guys can see we're kind
of maintaining the visual weight
of this sphere right now i can pull the
sphere away
let's turn it off and you can see
a general shape here we're going to get
this little bottom middle part which
will really help us
um but let's let's do that now okay so
i'm gonna do this let's get out of here
let's zoom up in here okay and this is
actually pretty cool if you
you can see this all move around that's
fun
all right so what we can do here is
let's grab that cube bring it out
pop it out here
hmm what's the best way to do this
um honestly we can probably
let's throw it in a cloner let's take
that cloner and set it to a
multi-instance to save on memory
let's also do ooh radial
maybe this will work um
interesting interesting i'm wondering if
this will work
if this doesn't work heck let's try it
if it doesn't work i have
an idea for another way but let's
take this down to like that
yep and let's push
maybe push this back um like it needs to
be instead of a circle it needs to be
like a like an oval
um my face guy my face guy thank you
my guy for the super chat he says love
your stuff
how you enjoying resuming content on
your channel i know you and the guys at
corridor are really close
i wanted to ask about the transition and
how it's going so far
it's going great man honestly it
couldn't be better i am loving
everything i'm doing on my channel it is
such a breath of fresh air for me to be
able to do this
you know i had my channel going for a
while i started it in 2006
got a lot of short films a lot of action
comedy
action drama short films on my channel
sci-fi action that kind of stuff
and you know that work stopped
it stopped and i didn't post a video in
like six years
this was when i was at rocket jump at
corridor
and it's the best because now i get to
return to it
i didn't i don't really have anxiety
about it anymore i used to
i used to think like oh people are i'm
going to post a video like oh what's
this i didn't subscribe for this
so i'm kind of in a sense restarting my
channel but i'm loving it
it's the best doing these streams with
you guys has been so cool
and helping you guys out with all of
your stuff at least a little bit
has been amazing for me as well so it's
it's been amazing
that's that's that's all i can say and i
still get to hang out with the corridor
guys
like i said we got lunch um yesterday
played a lot of smash bros and it was
cool
and adam thank you sir i appreciate you
um says hey clan i love your work and
started film college because of you holy
crap
um and the quarter crew and hope someday
be a group of filmmakers like
uh like yourselves yes dude keep it up
uh surround yourself with the people
that love doing what you love doing and
you'll do some pretty amazing stuff
because two heads are better than one i
promise you that that's the hardest
thing on my channel right now it's just
me
um i have my buddy cliff i'll go to
cliff's place i'm actually going over
there to
later today after this he works in
blender
and we come up with ideas together so
you guys watch the video of me
going away at corridor ren's advice to
me
of don't do it alone i i've
i've really kept that up i've taken all
three of their advice
um very seriously so
i brainstorm with my best friends when i
can and come up with some really cool
ideas but let's let's get back into it
you guys see what i mean you see how
this is kind of working
you're getting this dip in uh this dip
is caused by
things that are closer to camera so you
have the same size the object
uh further away from camera it'll look
smaller and it'll
move not as fast so you know we're
getting a little bit of something here
we'll obviously have to work with that
a little bit um
[Music]
and it's not quite the circular shape so
let's see what we can do
okay um let's give it a random effector
uh let's see with it selected let's drop
that on there
random effector scale y scale
so we want the bottom one
to really take the heat on it
um let's see
we can give these a little bit of random
rotation too
just a little bit yeah we want the
bottom one to take
the heat absolute scale how does what
does that do
well i guess they're all no
is there a way to change the
seed yes there is
all right so here's what i'm gonna do
let's get rid of let's
get rid of that and let's just
really go to town on this
and crank the seed and figure out the
seed that like
looks the best and i don't know why the
middle one isn't moving
there we go there we go you see what i
mean i think this one is nice
so what we can do is take that random
effector or the cloner rather and just
take the count up to 10 or something now
we need that natural dip
okay so here's what i'll do instead
i'm gonna hop out of here and i'll do it
linearly as opposed to
radial radially if that makes any sense
guys we got 1200 people up in the live
chat right now that's crazy
um my goodness
we're setting some records here guys we
are setting some records and i missed it
michael
flotron if flotron is your last name
that is the sickest last name ever
but it's probably pronounced flotrin um
you said shut up and take my money wait
no keep talking i like it
dude that's what's up man i appreciate
you man thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much
very generous of you um
heck yeah dude thanks for watching
thanks for hanging out with me i hope
you're learning something hope you're
getting some value from these streams
man
streaming is hard it's like how do i ah
i feel like if i'm not talking i'm not
being entertaining
i gotta entertain i gotta i gotta keep
talking gotta keep the numbers up
but you know then i'm like well maybe
i'm talking too much
i just i just can't shut up my throat's
starting to hurt it'd be nice to just
not talk
but then oh no the numbers are dropping
people are leaving because i'm not
talking they're not learning anything
that's what that's sometimes you know
sometimes that's where i'm at in my head
read of paw print of paul is doing god's
work
um i just realized that's another person
you're still doing god's work though
copperbot thank you for the super chat
he says hey will you be taking on
contract work or planning to go straight
into making your own projects
slash earning through streams and packs
um
yeah contract work not so much man not
so much it depends on the project but
i left corridor to pursue my stuff
not to pursue other people's stuff so
that's my motto that's what i'm sticking
to man i'm like
doing the best i can putting the value
putting
my time into my own self investing my
time
into myself and it's paying off it's
certainly paying off the channel has
been growing like crazy
you guys are coming back every single
week and it's really cool to see
um so i really appreciate that
and again it just depends on the project
it depends on the project
but let's get some work done guys let's
get some freaking
work done i'm i'm going in um all right
let's go linear with it
and we'll set that to zero hold shift
and
push these guys back let's set this to
i don't know six
and what kind of we basically what we
want to do is make
a
like a v a really long v if that makes
sense
let's hop into the camera and there you
go you see what i mean
it's doing its thing let's hop into the
random effector let's take
out the y scale and there you can see
it's pretty much
like perfectly working the sphere there
i can move these guys around
the random just a little bit open it up
a little bit
and we can work the rotation a touch as
well
and this is just going to be general
rubble and whatnot we're going to
replace these buildings with
with assets we'll dive into the assets
you know we'll probably build a little
asset pack and figure out where i'm
going to get all this crap from
it's not crappy i just i just talked
that way you know what i mean
the random uh let's see or the cloner
let's control drag it we'll copy it
we'll move it over and let's
adjust and kind of have it come to a v
point right there
and then let's go ahead and grab the
random effector go to the effector and
just adjust the ski
oh because it's the same one i see okay
okay well maybe then it's
seven buildings on this side i don't
know um let's undo that
what's the best way to do this
yeah we can do a little bit of this just
to mix it up a little bit you know
whoa go back in
and we can see we're kind of getting a
little something here
and let's move the cloner
um let's go ahead and hit that
keyframe let's move it over set that
keyframe
and bam everything's kind of moving
together
and the the little focal point the
ending point we can adjust
this value here so let's hop into the
camera and see what it looks like
we can keep it at the center basically
let's see bye
let's do a little bit of uh
so the z will make this bam right there
and then we'll adjust it back like that
cool so it's kind of moving
back and then we'll do the same for this
one here we'll hit that z
and slide it back like that
hit that keyframe
does it do anything
i mean you of just do that basically
boom
and something like that boom
so now we kind of have these buildings
moving a little bit
to fit that shape
now we'll see how that works
at in the end but that's basically kind
of what we have already
in our in our scene here we can have a
little bit of foreground elements too
so let me go ahead and save this
and this is going to help with fog
you'll actually be able to have these
buildings pushed into the background
with some fog
that's really gonna add depth to
our render you want as much depth well
not you don't want as much depth but
you want some depth in your render um
let's take this off
and there you can see we kind of have
that spherical shape maintained
as much as possible there really cool
yeah
oh alan mckay's up in here what's up
alan mckay
yo what's going on
hey good to see you man yeah we did a we
did a little podcast together maybe it's
coming out soon who knows
i'm excited for it i'm very excited for
it we talked about some good stuff and
i'm excited for you guys to see it
um what's up dude thank you for joining
that's really cool of you man
i appreciate it yeah i'm doing the
render here so let me show you my uh
my reference let me show you my
reference so this is my reference right
here
this is a little piece of concept
already put together um
maintaining the character and the sphere
because i gave everybody a template
with a character in it and a sphere
in it all right this is all of my
reference imagery
of the buildings most of it is from
hashima
battle battleship island or
maybe some of this stuff is from walled
city
i'm not really sure this is from kung fu
hustle one of my favorite movies of all
time
and this was my reference to like see
how a hole was punched out of some
buildings because that's kind of what
we're going to be doing
with the with this effect here um
yeah more buildings more buildings
definitely this is all hashima
this is from children of men i love this
movie so much it's an incredible movie
if you guys haven't seen it definitely
watch it
and it kind of goes over this is this is
like my look and feel and i'm using it
as foreground elements
same for here this is uh behind enemy
lines another one of my favorite movies
really cool scene so i'm kind of yeah
i'm
making it work making it happen let's
get our reference back
so what do we do from here um good
question
let's see if we can't get some temp
lighting going um
clayton potter thank you for the super
chat saying i wonder how the pipes call
in this one
for real though man love your streams
you inspire me so much to learn
you teach me how to think like an artist
dude that's awesome
that means a lot um
yeah dude i don't know i've just i've
been doing this for a while
and my way is certainly not the right
way
and it's not the wrong way either it's
just a way
and i'm hoping that some of the things
that i do
ring true to you guys and help you all
create some cool stuff
it's really cool what we've done
together over the last year
this is like basically the year
anniversary of me restarting the channel
and these streams maybe maybe next week
we'll do some year
anniversary thing i don't know who knows
but let's uh let's get some temp
lighting up in here you know what i mean
let's hit render on this bad boy and see
what we can see
let's save this stuff evolver thank you
so much you're here every single week
and you do the super chat every week man
i really appreciate you for other
reasons too for considering me
for all the cool stuff you're doing so
thank you sir
stay true to myself yes sir will do
that's the way to go absolutely okay so
guys we want to make sure we're seeing
just what we want to see in the render
by that i mean we don't want this top
bar stuff so let's hit the lock button
and then let's scale it down to 0.5 0.4
yeah something like that so we can see
what we're seeing you know what i mean
now let's get some light up in here
let's get some temp light so
i'm gonna make an hdri environment
and let's go with the color
the color i'm gonna sample my reference
um
[Music]
something like this
a little darker perhaps let's
throw a octane tag onto the camera
camera imager turn that on i always i'll
switch this to linear
2.2 um
maybe a little vignette on it just a
touch
saturate to white is point two that
means any bright light that is shining
in the camera
its color will actually be white the
source
will be white just like in real life but
the fall off will be the color you
choose
um i am a fan of portrait 400
i'm a big fan of portrait 400. it kind
of has a
greenish tint to things
which i love um
so maybe this is like a a temp situation
that'll work for us
let's go ahead and
hit the scene with a light so let's
let's get out of here
and let's make a big old area light
maybe perhaps a sunlight that's what we
could do
all right and let's work this sunlight
around
and try and get it right
up in here
something like that maybe
i don't want it to be
too bright and sunny but we'll change
the lighting i'm going to change the
lighting
most definitely as we move
uh through our render
maybe something like that i'm not quite
sure yet
how that's going to work but maybe we
can do something like that and then
we'll take the daylight let's go to the
sunlight tag and we'll take the sun size
to like i don't know 20.
that's really going to soften up our
shadows um and let's go ahead
and mix it with the sky texture
um
[Music]
let's do by taking the sun size to 20
it smooths out our shadows
that's exactly what that does mix with
the sky texture so
maybe we just do like a hdri environment
or something uh crude characters thank
you for the super chat
due to you and the quarter crew i'm
getting started with digital art and
have learned so much thank you hope to
do more with unreal engine 4 can't wait
um to make a game and god help the
computer you use
yeah absolutely yeah i have a really
cool idea
for an unreal engine uh
concept that
kind of um how do i say this
it's an idea i have that incorporates a
lot
of the cool stuff we've been doing over
the last year into one place
and it is an interactive thing that you
guys can
hop into so that's all i'll say
um it's gonna be sweet i'll be working
on that
this year for sure i hope to get it done
by this year
i'll be streaming some stuff too more on
that later but right now
we're doing some cool art
all right
so let's see
i'm wondering um
it's definitely like an overcast
situation um i'm thinking
like the roofing and stuff will help
shadow
the foreground environment
but this isn't like this isn't far off
maybe ins excuse me maybe instead of
that sun
we will do an area light pardon me
oh boy let's bring this up we'll scale
it up
what's going on oh that's rotation
and we'll have it face the front
remember that remember that little trick
i showed you guys
in the uh the art breakdown i did
last week or two weeks ago the area
light trick
where you scale up the area light
and you blast some good old light onto
our scene
that's exactly what i'm doing right now
i'm just giving it a little bit of fill
light maybe we can go all the way back
here
up with it and it's just a giant
global kind of a situation
that we can scale up
just a massive light in the sky yep
that's the sun that's what a sun does
but we can hide this a little bit better
i think without having to use an hdri
hdri environment um
the bounce light on this thing is nutty
bring it up
yeah could be interesting i think it's a
little too early to say
this is right or wrong
but it's doing something off and on it
just helps
helps our scene a little bit so i'm
gonna go ahead and uh
save this this is kind of our block out
here it's a very rough block out of our
scene
so let's start sourcing like
hmm what do we want to do how do we want
to do this let me go through the mega
scans library
because the quick quick so swooped in
y'all
um and they're hooking it up i think
quicksole you guys get a year-long
subscription to quixo mega scans for
winning
all five first second third
fourth and fifth place get a year-long
quixo
membership so that's pretty sweet
graham welcome you're not late you can
always watch the video late a little bit
later
it's gonna be on youtube forever you
know how it is um
but welcome welcome to the stream good
to see ya
god dang i love mega scans so much they
have the best stuff
let's go full screen with it bam
yeah good times up in here so i'm
looking at my reference
and we're going to need a few things
maybe we're getting ahead of ourselves
with this
but i'm going to need to start building
out some things first i think i'm going
to do the foreground first
i will do my foreground first and then
i'll work on the background very similar
to how i did it for the art breakdown
right you guys remember the the car by
the water
yeah so we'll let's see what we can find
on mega scans i'm just gonna favorite
the stuff
so i can pull it into my scene so i'm
gonna go to my favorites
you can see here this is all the stuff
from the car one so i'm gonna unfavorite
all this
and build a new favorites list for this
project okay
let's go to the home page and see
what we need um let's let's go to the 3d
assets
and find like a i don't know
3d assets um industrial
street let's try industrial construction
sweet demolished yes yes please
i mean i can just favorite all this
stuff right now because this is all good
stuff that we can use to build out
and shape our scene with
okay let's go to
rubble yes please concrete pile
yeah a freaking bulk bag yeah
all this stuff is such good stuff
i'm just gonna favorite all of this
because we really want lots of detail
in our render in our scene and this is
going to add
all of it it's so good so good
um debris pallets yeah we want dude
literally everything here we just want
all of this stuff
um
[Music]
like i just want all of this and it's
gonna help us
oh boy it will help us um palette yeah
what's up in palette okay
got some cool stuff up in palette maybe
there's some pallets in the foreground
we can favorite that stuff um barrels
mining hardware electrical nuts and
bolts like dude
all of this stuff we can use except for
this
well maybe we do want this who knows but
i kind of want to build out a world
that is here's my idea for the scene
if you guys are just joining i basically
want to have
a couple massive robots fallen over
in this world and
i want there to be like a lot of foliage
and greenery
to spice up this kind of decayed
desaturated look and i want this
character
carrying or dragging some sort of like
cargo box full of plants and it's like
with every step it's taking it's growing
plants or something i don't know
um basically restoring life to a
destroyed world
is what i want to do um
so i have to figure out how to do those
robots i've been watching uh yasuke have
you guys seen yasuke on netflix
oh boy is that good and that's kind of
what got me the idea for the robot stuff
the hard hat can be good little
construction helmet
that's nice these pipes
the modular pipe pack is going to be
good maybe some beams like this
a little bit of pvc pipe and all this
will be great for us these things these
rusted over boxes are going to be
awesome
um let's see mining
uh maybe these guys these hydraulic
pumps and beams will be really nice for
us
cart wheels yeah yeah railway be cool to
have a little railway through the middle
of this scene
storage yes barrels there's a freaking
barrel
right up in there let's get a barrel
going
um this rusted barrel oh my god dude all
this stuff is so good
this is gonna be all up in the render
yeah freaking bean cans rusty tank it's
like fall out up in here we're going to
have
the most mega scans assets i've ever had
in us
this is going to be absurd
oh that's gonna be awesome yeah
canisters and tanks yes please maybe we
put two of these on our character's back
maybe that's what they're carrying is
like a bunch of canisters or something
um all right street
let's hit the streets trash can we could
probably use
maybe use a trash can curbs maybe we
could like build out a little street
scene
no parking sign that'd be pretty funny
actually in the background
parking meter maybe yeah he's crossing a
street
hmm
yeah this is all good stuff um
yeah electrical boxes fire hydrant like
it's just gonna be
so much stuff in our scene and we're
gonna have to place it very
strategically um
[Music]
yeah barriers we can probably hit some
of these concrete barriers i would love
to have uh
some like barbed wire fences but i don't
think mega scans has
barbed wire fences right now let's get
these concrete barriers
these are really cool mega scan city up
in here
sweet okay
all right
all right we can pause our render
and think about how let's see how we
want to do this
it's the foreground i want to get the
foreground first
like i said
so i think it's time to start playing
with some materials
all right
the materials are going to get out of
hand pretty quick okay
so we're going to need to do a good job
of organizing this stuff
i'm going to start with one of my
favorite materials
one of my go-to's i'm going to start
with a glossy material
and
is dying what is happening cinema 4d
hold on
what the heck
what's going on what the hey
rca film productions shout outs for the
super chat
says thank you so much for this and also
darn you for executing my idea first and
better
dang man i'm sorry
i'm sorry how funny is that how how is
it that like
one person has an idea but another
person had that same idea
and they never had any communication
like that's a thing right that's weird
there's just a lot of ideas out there i
guess two
and one or two of them is bound to cross
paths at a certain point
all right so i don't know why why you
can
make a mega scans glossy material that's
what i want glossy material
mega scans go thank you all right node
editor bam let's get this up in here
i don't know why this glitches out every
time but
here we go i like to have my node editor
in my main view because i don't need it
ever when i'm working in this view so i
just
make it this view here um let's
see like i was saying guys my favorite
material
one of my favorite materials my go-to
materials is gonna have to be rd
textures already textures
is one of the
one of the best i'd say the highest
quality texture packs
ever uh rd stands for real displacement
let's see let's see where are you
textures party textures
all right ooh rusty floor what does
rusty floor look like
oh that's nice guys we're gonna have so
much
detail and texture in our scene it's
gonna be nuts
sand dirty muddy let's see
okay now it's not sand we're going for
where are you
um tire
marks on soil and in mud i think this
one is it
yeah this one's pretty good probably
grab this one
so let's build this out tire marks i'm
gonna grab the 4k
texture for now
and update it with the 8k texture as
needed because
this scene is gonna get out of hand
y'all it's going to get crazy
so we want to maintain as much vram as
possible
um because it's going to get nutty all
right i'll tell you that much
depth 4k gloss we want the wet gloss
actually no we're going to do this with
dizzy vipers puddle maps
um let's see
high gloss on the
let's see what is it gloss drying gloss
dry gloss white gloss wet
eye gloss there's a lot of gloss huh
there's okay there's six different
choices i see
we want tire marks high gloss
sure let's go with the high gloss i
guess we can change it out
4k
versions let's go 4k we want the dry dry
dry we want
wet 4k wet roughness
god that's confusing dry and wet and
normal
roughness wet okay
um let's drag these in
so here's a little quick tip for you
guys
all of these textures all of these uh
these image textures the ones that are
black and white
they come in as color textures in c4d by
default
and we do not want that so we're going
to take them all
and set them to float textures to
maintain
as much vram as possible let me give you
an example i'll render the scene
and i'll show you my my info
let's get at the info up in here okay
you see this
you this is kind of tiny but used free
and total vram we have 1.127 gigabytes
used all right now if i go into
my textures and i grab all the black and
white maps and i set them to
float you should see that number go down
but maybe it didn't go down because it's
not applied so let me apply it
to a plane on the ground
we'll get that going let's hop
in let's just apply everything first
so we want our diffuse this is our
glossy wet
so gloss is specular but inverted
this is our normal 4k normal
we have roughness wet we'll drop that
into roughness
we have a bump map and we have a
depth matte or displacement map
then we'll pipe right in to here and
let's
take this height to 10 is fine 0.5
and 4k resolution
we'll move this up just a little bit to
see
our ground plane very nice
obviously we'll adjust the crap out of
this but that's the idea here
very very cool so you can see used
free and total vram is 1.35 right now
if i were to take those black and white
maps
and change them back to color
so normal it sees a 1.49
but you change them to float since
they're all black and white you change
them to black and white
float textures 1.49 goes to 1.35
and you need to do this for every single
one right
from mega scans you can bring them in
and they'll come in as float by default
because mega scans is hooked up they're
awesome select all your crap
right click it auto arrange
uh select all your crap right click auto
arrange yeah and then you can kind of
get a little
a little cleaner layout i'm pretty ocd
about stuff so
i like to have everything kind of
aligned in a very particular way
but that's just me
very nice
sweet
so i'm gonna save a new version here o2
and let's switch this out for another
another texture i'm kind of building my
assets here
i'm building and collecting all of the
the textures that i know i'm going to
use or mess with
so we're going to do this just by
control dragging
and let's go ahead and uh hop in here
and switch this out for another texture
all right so there's another one i
believe
tire marks on mud tire marks on soil
see what this soil one looks like
yeah this is a good one right here this
is a really good one i used this one
for my first parallel dimensions
render um it's a good one
so let's go in here and let's start
replacing some of these so the bump
4k bump we'll get that um
we want color wet 4k
color wet we want 4k depth we're just
dragging dropping and replacing we want
glossy
wet um in the specular
and then the normal 4k normal of course
and we want
wet roughness there you go
and now we kind of have
some wet muddy nastiness
let's take let's see this displacement
up to like
30. and if we pick it up you know you
can see it gets really
chunky you know that's what i want that
chunkiness
that's good stuff so right now we have
one and two
and we can of course adjust the color on
these to mix them together a little bit
more
and you notice what that backlight is
doing for us without that backlight
you're not getting that gloss and it
pick it really picks up
we can take that down to 15 something a
little bit more subtle
but this is really going to help us to
bring out the detail
of our you know our foreground
let me slide this a little bit closer
all right so it's going to get really
cool we're kind of close to the ground
the camera's a little close to the
ground
um we can always go camera uncheck check
camera
and then we can adjust this on the fly
here
and another thing you see how it's
stretching with this you can just go to
the plane
and we will take the uv mapping to cubic
and now all the scaling happens uh
separate from how we stretch the plane
so we can
you know select this little scale thing
here scale it up to really adjust that
um let's see we can take the plane
and get him walking on the plane there
and it might be a little too chunky so
we can adjust the
displacement map instead of 30 let's go
to 15
and kind of bring it down
but this is just this is just an example
we're going to switch out all of these
textures
and and all that good stuff but we're
going to build our list
first all right we're going to build out
our texture our texture pack and
everything and obviously you can see
already
that the ground is a little bit
different than my
my reference like the angle is higher
here
versus here so everything's really going
to come together in the render obviously
the concept is just there to guide our
eye
all right
oh yeah ronin good shout out so yeah
ronan just posted a link i'll pin it um
we got a instagram create with clint
instagram
that uh the mods put together and it's a
place for us to
post all of the winners of the weekly
challenge
um and be able to share all your guys's
work and stuff i've been retweeting
all of your guys's uh uh work in
progresses for this challenge on twitter
and and uh you know on instagram too
definitely hit me up
create with clint um or punisher i'll
share it i can send it to the create
with clint and i'll share it on there
um i'll do both but yeah i'm gonna kind
of share everyone's work here
as we i'll work hard on this stuff
together
but let's keep building out a list of
yeah let's keep building out our list of
textures and stuff
weird why is the why is it not
moving with the
oh because the check camera thing
probably
there we go oh that's going to be so
cool
yeah you see the way it reveals the
foreground
like that's that is awesome that's why i
love the side scroller idea
because there's so many different little
story elements that can be revealed
as we go through our world
but let's keep going let's keep building
out our
uh our texture pack keep going with this
so i'm just gonna um
delete that
and keep building it from this point um
there's some other really good arty
texture packs let's go
let's keep looking let's keep going
photo scans now info here we go so this
is like kind of your overview of stuff
and it looks like our scene um this
sand dirty muddy could be interesting
but there's a lot of debris in the
ground there's a lot of like
a lot of crap you know in the ground so
it might be cool to grab i don't know
sand dirty muddy could be cool
let's load that one in that one that
one's got potential
sand dirty muddy alright so let's
control drag this out we'll hop in
and uh and make this one happen here
boom
the reason why i don't know i don't know
why but for me i'm pretty obsessed
with like the semi wet
um overcast lighting because you get so
much detail
here's an example this render or this
render
this would be a fun render to do
but this shot here this is a alfonso
coron i believe children of men
and look at all the detail you see a lot
of the detail in the wall
because of its because it's backlit
right
so you're getting a nice highlight on
the far
side and a shadow on the on the close
side and that gives you a really cool
detail really cool texture and it brings
out the grunginess of your scene
and i am a sucker for
urban exploring abandoned places
dirty places forgotten places like i
love it so much because it just has so
much texture to it
that's why i love construction sites
abandoned buildings
um you know there's just yeah there's
just infinite texture to that stuff
and it's a really cool world to be in i
think my love for this came from like
half-life
and silent hill when i was a kid
you know playing those games is just the
best
all right
all right here we go so
let's replace this one yeah
sand dirty muddy so let's grab that bump
we're just connecting everything this is
the boring stuff you know
we got our color our depth
um muddy let's see
muddy gloss or high gloss yeah we're
fine with the normal gloss
um let's get our normal map and our
roughness
so we can probably bring down the
roughness here it's a little intense
but we'll adjust that as needed once we
start throwing our stuff
in and we can probably throw a bit more
displacement on this
15 maybe even 30 to give us a little bit
more
texture to our sand here
awesome now like i said we're gonna have
a lot of materials we're gonna have a
lot of stuff going on
so we want to we want to organize all
this stuff so i'm gonna
right click select all this stuff we're
gonna right click it we're to add it to
a new layer
we'll double click this new layer and
we'll call this rd textures
and you can organize this however you
want you could just have a
textures folder you can have a mega
scans folder i know i'm probably going
to want um let's go to
create edit view
select what is it how do i make a new
layer
no layer all um create
materials default material
weird there's probably a way i'll go
layers
rd textures right click new layer here
we go
but it's not showing up hmm it's not
showing up
can i duplicate this ctrl drag
mega scans
no okay well maybe we'll just do it as
we go oh yeah we have our rd textures
i'm gonna
grab a couple more they have some really
good like broken concrete ones that i
want to mess with
so let's check those out um rd textures
destructed floor this is the good stuff
all right so let's check these out
um textures
and oh also you know what i'm gonna do
i've never done this before but i feel
like this could help me
um is include these textures in my purif
board
for quick uh
kind of a quick look you know what i
mean so let's grab the ones that we've
used so far
we have tire marks and soil
so we'll go to the demo on that
and we'll just drag that in and we'll do
the other one in mud
let's grab that demo we have that one
and
we have the uh
sand dirty muddy we'll grab that demo as
well
this is what we're working with right
now
it's a really good reference for us to
see um
so let's try some of these destructive
floors um
let's do the demos yes please
oh this is such a good one yeah you see
all these little rubble pieces
in the floor that's what we want like
that's super solid but let's keep going
through and see what they have
um i like that one though so i'm
actually gonna drag it out
into our
oh come on
like that's so good
destructive floor two
let's go larger on this
this is very similar looks like it's
just some like
little rocky pieces oh i don't want to
do that
cool what else do we have let's check
more um
very similar destructive floor 3 is very
similar
but it looks like it has some like
bricks in it and stuff
really nice
in pure ref double tap an image
ah
hey that's good i like that thank you
for that tip i'm always learning from
you guys
hey cg geek what's up dude
welcome welcome to the stream welcome to
the channel dude hey i don't forget
i don't forget i remember you left a
comment
on the parallel dimensions video say hey
i gotta give this a shot next time
dude i would be honored if you did
something with this
uh alternate realities challenge that'd
be freaking sweet man i would love to
see what you could do
i challenge you personally i challenge
you
if you have time
welcome dude thanks for joining i'm just
pulling a different
different textures here
and we're building out our material
material list that's going to go
to build out our ultimate
bam this is our this is my reference
right now
is right here so we're going to try and
make this happen
looks like you got some fans in the in
the live chat man that's awesome very
cool
okay okay moving on y'all let's keep
making some cool stuff we got some
destructive ground to play with here but
i want to keep going through
and just get a good vibe and a good
sense
of all of these different ones it looks
like these first
five or so are pretty similar or at
least the first three
lots of bricks and rubble this is gonna
be great we're gonna need a lot of this
here
um
[Music]
let's let's grab this
just keep grabbing all this stuff to
take a look at it
oh okay are we mixing it up a little bit
this is almost like it was paved over or
something
um destructive floor 7 has no
demo but yo this one's so good look at
this one
it's like a pock marked tile i
i know i want this one i'm gonna just
throw this one in right now because it's
freaking awesome
um sweet cg geek yeah man
you'll join if you have the time i i
couldn't ask anything else of you i know
you're super busy um running a youtube
channel and probably
you know if you have a wife and kids you
know like it's a lot of work so
i hear you man but it's cool that you're
here man it's cool that you're joining
the
going in the stream all right let's
build out this texture guys let's do it
this is super fun stuff
all right i'm going to control drag this
one we'll double click we'll go in
go into the node editor let's get this
live viewer popping off let's render it
and see what we can make all right
all right so let's go ahead and grab our
color
this is only an 8k texture
and let's come on load for me
i'm gonna apply it of course
i'm gonna build this from scratch and
show you guys how cool this is
um
let's see
i'll walk you through step by step each
little piece
so let's start with the displacement map
okay
so the displacement map we need to
change out
is actually adjusting um and moving
the the physical
geometry of the piece or of this texture
let's turn off this light now the light
kind of helps doesn't it
but you see how it's like getting this
this nice little concrete look here
um let's go with the normal map next and
the normal map
is it's it's fake detail
and it's just kind of moving pixels up
and down
left and right based off its color it's
a blue little texture there so we're
getting some extra detail
now the bump channel is very similar to
normal except
the bump is um
is moving these pixels up and down
moving these points up and down based
off of a black and white image
so you need some really fine detail in
here now
and it's again it's fake detail it's not
moving any geometry whereas the depth
here is actually moving geometry but
since we're in octane it's not moving
the geometry it's still faking it
because it's doing a a texture
displacement if i was doing a vertex
displacement
this is what you'd get something a lot
more
low res low quality um the rest of this
stuff is just the noise in the
uh yeah look this is this is our
our displacement map when i set it to
vertex displacement that's because we
need more polygons
for this to work if i set this to 100 by
100 you can see it starts to
work a little bit
100 by 100 should
do something vertex let's re-render it
there you go you see now it's like okay
we're getting a little bit more detail
but we have to take this up to a
thousand by a thousand
ah hold on no that's gonna destroy my
computer
a thousand by a thousand and we'll
re-render that
and like we're barely getting more
detail come on
but it's taking so much energy to do it
it's like ah we have a
million polygons and this is what we're
getting nah
set that junk to one by one son
one by one change
your displacement method your type to
texture displacement and it just does it
all for free
it's incredible absolutely incredible
and that's just the displacement we pipe
in the bump map
and the normal and you get even more
detail out of this it's
insane very cool stuff but let's keep
going
we're not done we still have the gloss
and the color and all that stuff too so
let's do the
roughness let's grab our roughness drop
that in there and that's going to make
it look
like uh like it's not a clean waxed car
it's gonna dirtied up a little bit more
it's gonna break up those reflections
and same for the the gloss
we can even let's go high gloss
and gloss is the invert of specular so
you'll want to flip those around
but there we go we got our gloss on our
specular and now finally we add the
color
and you have your full texture
and it looks beautiful
get up in there it's insane the amount
of detail on this is crazy
rd textures man they're the best
and if for whatever reason your um
i know you guys can't really see it
because my head is in the way here on
the stream
but just below here we have our textures
and
my one texture is just white just double
click this little preview window and
it'll update it
in the small view if that makes any
sense
if you're having the problem you know
what i mean if you're not having the
problem then don't even worry about it
so let's keep going let's keep finding
some cool textures um
destructive floor oh we got destructed
walls now
this stuff is interesting kind of like a
torn wall
with some uh
insulation on the inside that's yeah
that's interesting but this i don't know
i'm less concerned about the walls right
now
and more so the
the ground plane
but let's just see what they got
like that's a pretty cool texture most
of the stuff you can get from uh
from mega scans though it's just like
the grounds here
are really cool oh that's a nice one
though we could probably use that
yeah that's definitely mega scans one
this one's cool because it has some
pipes hanging out the wall
i really like that
this one too yeah let's let's build
these two really quick i like those a
lot
oh man i keep doing that i keep closing
it down um textures arty textures
destructed wall six
and seven textures we want the 4ks
so 4k bump we want 4k
color 4k depth
4k gloss
4k normal and 4k
roughness
look at that look how crazy that is that
displacement map is nuts huh
that's what makes these rd textures so
nice is their displacement maps they're
insane
and finally um we'll do one more
and we'll figure out where to go next
here let's plug this in
destructive wall seven go into textures
and we want our 4k
bump the 4k color
4k depth 4k
gloss 4k normal
and 4k hit roughness
there we go and we got a really nice
destructed wall
really good i'm super happy with that
let's add these
actually they're already added very nice
because we were just duplicating okay
cool
all right so we have some fun ground uh
textures and stuff let's just duplicate
this
and show you guys what we're working
with
and we can hide our character for a
second too
so yeah we got a couple walls and we got
some
we got like ground texture here we got
this muddy ground we got this muddy
ground
i'm gonna bring in actually one of the
uh
one of these guys here that we were
looking at maybe two different ones
so based off of our reference
there's a lot of rubble in the ground a
lot of
dirt and trash and stuff we can add to
this and
this is all mega scans we'll add all
these like things here
this frame in the ground is really cool
i want to do some frames in the ground
it looks like a bed
it's totally a bed that's amazing um
so let's see if we can't pull two of
these
that look like that this one is good
this one is good like these honestly
these are all really good
um let's go with one that's a bit more
dirty so maybe this one
yeah this one here number one
and and number five number one and
number five let's try those out
all right um let's go with the bump
4k color i'm skipping the ao ambient
occlusion
i probably just don't need it
we can always come back to it you know
let's go with the high gloss on this one
normal and roughness and what i do i'm
doing the 4ks again because i want to
save as much vram as possible it's going
to get out of hand very quick
so um i can always switch them out for
8k textures
when i need to but look at that isn't
that crazy
how good that looks
absolutely insane um
and one more one more let's do
number five i believe it was right i
keep god i keep closing this screen
that's why i need a third monitor for
you know
number five
where are you where are you sir
was it six or five
that was five
yeah okay
all right let's go with that bump color
depth high gloss
normal and roughness by now you guys
should know these are the ones these are
the go-to's
these are the hits
boom
sick all right so we got some
nice ground textures that we can work
with here
make things nice and muddy and gross we
can change the color of it so if you
guys
want to change this color we can hop
into the node editor and we'll give this
a color correction node
and we can just you know maybe
i don't know turn up the gamma 1.2
1.4 take the saturation down to 0.8
0.7
and now it's kind of looking very
similar
to this mud you know so you're gonna
have to color correct these together um
and we're gonna mix them together too
with octane mix nodes and stuff
let's get our character back
awesome awesome awesome lots of fun
stuff to work with now it'd be cool to
have
this should be a lot of sourcing of
materials today so
let's let's look at this here we have a
really nasty road
some concrete that's all busted up over
here there's like a little
brick area with some stone steps and
stuff that could be nice
i'm just looking at this to try and see
how we can lay this out so
let's go ahead and organize our crap we
definitely need to organize all this
because it's going to get out of hand
it's gonna be a big scene so let's right
click
uh control click all this lighting
business
control and alt g group and i'm gonna
call this lights
and then let's go ahead and group all of
our
uh our buildings and stuff alt ge i'm
gonna call this
uh i'll call this block out
and then i'm gonna put that into its own
folder with the ground and all these
planes and stuff
and let's alt g and call this
geo for geometry
character and camera i'll leave outside
of that and then
this random modifier i'll throw that
into geometry
for our block out too
so how you guys doing
i'm gonna take a little chill break here
guys give me some thumbs ups if you guys
are doing okay if you guys are learning
stuff
um smiley face you know throw me throw
me a little something are you guys doing
all right
are you guys working on your render if
you guys are working on your render
um give me a little star emoji or
something
vance are we allowed to add more
characters in our scene well that is a
question that's answered in the faqs on
the discord
but you can add whatever you want as
long as
the main character in that sphere
uh maintain the same visual weight
and are kind of the the uh i don't know
the center point
of your render that's all good
sweet guys we got some happy people we
got some stars people working on the
renders very cool
again we have until june first ooh
sotomonte's working on his
yeah we got a lot of freaking stars up
in here
it's gonna be some really awesome
renders but like i was gonna say
guys we're we got till june 1st so
take your time with it you can see i'm
not rushing this process please take
your time with it
make it look as nice as possible because
we want to make this render montage as
epic as possible so keep it up keep up
that good work
um jeez sotomante says okay so talking
about the discord we're almost at 20k
oh my god that's insane guys 20k
members on the discord it's incredible
my goodness and you guys have kept it
such a fun creative place
let's keep it up let's keep it that way
it's a very clean
creative supportive environment and
that's exactly
the way i want to keep it so freaking
good work everybody you guys are amazing
it's really rare to say that there's 20k
people
in the discord server and it's not just
a freaking
crap shoot of like just
random vulgar stuff um so you guys
congratulations to y'all for keeping it
such a clean and fun place to be
that's amazing that's very amazing and
to the mods too
to all my mods shout outs let's get them
all we got
sotomonte and darren winkle the ogs the
original mods who helped me uh
early last year and then just recently
maybe a month ago
we brought on some good people we got
visual we got
mdk we have ronin and we have
sipo and i feel like
i'm not missing someone somebody and if
i am i'm
terribly sorry there's a lot of there's
a lot going through my brain
on these streams you know but i think
that's everybody
cypo mdk ronin visual sodamonte and
deerin
yeah all right y'all
um where are we at how are we feeling
i'm excited that i've got this render
started we're two hours into the stream
um maybe we can go for another hour or
something
i'm feeling it
um oh here's another question that's in
the faqs but an important one
he says should i use the default
character
well
uh again it's in the faqs you can change
the character out for whoever
or whatever you want as long as there's
a character uh with two legs and two
arms
and a heck i don't know what if there's
four arms or whatever but like it just
needs to be a character walking like
this character is walking you need to
slap
it onto this animation
[Music]
so yes you should change the character
out
but the character here is there in case
y'all are super lazy and you don't do
that
or you feel that this is the exact
character you want
it's there for you just in case all
right but yes switch it out have fun
with it yeah
how to submit great question there isn't
oh yeah polygon
i did miss somebody and polygon
the last mod thank you guys
um so
yeah there's no submission link yet
there will be this week
but i specifically didn't want to add
one because guys you shouldn't be
submitting already take your time on
your renders please
uh you have the time so take the time
definitely take the time
i think we're going to be doing it
through google we've got a little google
sheet situation going where you can
submit and we have some very specific
submission requirements that if you do
not follow
let's just say you want to follow those
submission requirements that's all i'm
going to say all right
one dead duck thanks for the super chat
team apocalyptic let's go
absolutely um i'm excited to see your
render dude you always put out good
stuff
ah what else guys what else
yeah what happens if there's a thousand
renders in the compilation what am i
gonna do
let's do the math
1000 renders times 5
because it's 5 seconds divided by 60
is 83 minutes
yeah divided by 60 again is an hour
about an hour and 30 minutes hour and 38
minutes i guess is that what that is
um it's going to be insane let me just
say it's going to be insane if there's 2
000 submissions
we're going to nearly be at three hours
and that'll officially be my first
feature film
yeah i don't know we'll have to see
if i get a bunch of freaking troll
submissions then
those probably wouldn't make it in the
stream or in the montage but if you guys
actually apply yourself and work hard
then it'll be in there it'll be there
for sure
we'll have to see um i might do a top
100 montage
and then i'll do like the full montage
which will be like three hours long
i'll just have to see really we'll have
to see my intention is to include
everybody
it just matters like just depends on how
many submissions we get
um but even if we get a million
submissions i want to do i want to
figure out a way to show everyone's
stuff
in a montage yeah we'll figure it out
guys don't worry
we'll figure it out
hmm
all right
let's uh let's lay out some groundwork
i am a fan of the mud right here
i'm also a fan of this
broken rubbly ground right here i think
this one's a solid one
to include this one the broken tiles i'm
not sure where i'll put this
yet this is more of an indoor deal i'm
not who knows
this one we'll see i'm not sure where to
put that either
this one could be mixed with this one
and that could be mixed with this one
for some cool stuff
superior productions what up you say do
like multiple episodes with seasons
oh that's interesting and release them
i don't know at least one a month i
don't know that that's an interesting
interesting one oh screen switch thank
you
thank you guys
hmm
i appreciate you all y'all helping me
out all the time
god this is gonna be so much work this
could be so much work
but it's gonna be worth it
absolutely be worth it
all right
so let's lay out a single
material and then we'll go from there
we'll make it more advanced from there
okay
so geometry
and these planes here
um we'll hop out of the camera you know
here's what i'll do
we'll take the camera option one check
the check camera option which is
confusing
i just need to update my octane i know
they switched it up a little bit more
and let's grab
this muddy guy over here
let's lay this out
so my camera is let's see
let's uh let's take my ground
plane turn it off
and then we'll take this guy we'll zero
it out
and why is it there we go okay okay
boom there we go that's what we need now
it's on the ground
let's scale it
just to as far as we need you see i
don't need to come any closer to camera
i want to save as
much computer juice as possible my
goodness
and we can do this in little strips too
so this will just be like our initial
foreground piece
and again we'll change this to cubic
and you can see it's tiling pretty bad
um
let's go into full view
and see what it looks like i don't want
to scale this up too much because i want
the detail to be maintained
we can rotate it
to get a little bit less tiling going on
there
you guys see how that worked
so the difference you can see the tiles
going
into the uh the vanishing point
but if we rotate it just a bit it throws
off the vanishing point and kind of
turns it out over this way
but let's go ahead and scale it up just
a little bit
and this will be fixed definitely when
we um
when we start blending these materials
together with other materials okay
so let's go to the displacement and
let's set this to 20.
15 is nice
okay
now we have this guy this wet road as
well
so we can make a mixed material
i'll make a mix material
we'll add this to the rd textures layer
we'll apply our mixed material and we'll
hop
and know how is this going to work
because this placement only works
um you can use one displacement on a
mixed material
um i don't know if anyone knows a way
around that we got some super chats to
address
i just realized so jordan
thank you for the super chat much
appreciated
what was the inspiration behind uh the
walking animation you did for this
challenge
i just wanted to do something a little
different than just a simple walk
um i wanted to be a bit more dynamic and
i wanted people to
envision a little bit more something
than just walking so is this character
what are they holding a backpack
are they pulling something like what are
they doing
so i wanted to make it a little bit more
dynamic in that sense
and just 3d things thank you for the
super chat
very generous of you um that is amazing
you say more work more awesomeness love
the stream so far thanks for doing it
every week clint
uh yeah dude i got you man i got you
um it's nice though it's nice it's a
nice balance because sometimes i'll
release edited videos on the weekend
which gives me a chance to relax and
take a weekend to
catch up and refresh but i feel great
today because i hadn't streamed in a
minute so we're doing it together
and it feels good
but we want to mix material like i said
we want to mix material
between
this guy holding shift will move the
entire
uh structure material one
and material to
drag this out
and i'll mix them together with a noise
node
and let's just go ahead and set this to
cubic as well
and they're being mixed together right
now with a float node set to 0.5 so in
one direction
it is one material set to one
it's another material and notice there's
no displacement map so we need to fix
that
but we'll go ahead and delete the float
texture
and let's pipe in a noise node
octane noise we'll give it a projection
and a transform
let's set the contrast to a thousand
that way we can see what we're doing we
can right click and solo it just to get
a better idea as well
and we can transform it up so it's a
little bit larger like this
and then we take the contrast back down
once we
dial in the shape
a little bit something like that hop
back into our camera
and we can maybe take the transform back
down like 15 or something
10 perhaps and let's adjust the octaves
to like 8
and the omega to 0.8 so it gets a bit
more detail
right and maybe we take the transform we
keep taking the transform down
one two maybe
i don't know maybe five or something
and it's the displacement is what we
need so
let's pipe in this displacement here
and it's not looking the greatest
because we're still getting like what
the tiling
so we have that displacement we also
have this displacement
and we want to certainly combine these
two together so i think there's like a
displacement mixer
vertex displacement mixer i've never
used this though
so displacement 1 displacement 2
and then does that just combine them
together but it doesn't look like
they're working
blend weight i i don't know how this
works does anyone know how the
displacement mixer works in octane
matthew why don't i add background ambi
music to my streams well
one i don't have a background ambient
music
that goes for that long two
i'd rather you guys just add your own
music in the background
that way it doesn't get ridiculous you
know what i mean
uh adam you say just got into 3d
recently have you been a huge
inspiration
thank you for all the amazing work thank
you for the super chat thanks for
joining me thanks for learning with me
man
yeah we're doing it together thank you
sir
um steven vazquez i see you okay
thank you for the super chat you say uh
would this work with rotoscoping i'm not
very savvy with this type of content
maybe i can
make a cool animation by the way i'm new
here but loving the content
thank you man thank you so much yeah so
i guess the contest is a 3d
contest i never really had someone ask
can you do it with
footage but i mean give it a shot dude
that sounds really cool
um yeah freaking
rotoscope it give it a shot yeah like i
said it sounds
sounds pretty sweet and alan
um says what do you think of making this
challenge
result in nft um
i am 100 against
selling everyone's work as
an nft in collecting money for that that
would be
very not chill of me to do
i'll sell my own as an nft you guys can
sell your individual ones as nfts but
i'm not going to take the montage and
sell the montage
maybe in the future we can do a
a a charity one where everyone comes
together and we try and make as much
money for charity as possible
i would do that but not this time around
it would have to be announced as a
charity one um from the beginning
but that's a good question alan thank
you for asking
um so yeah the octane mixer you have to
mix texture not displacement
or octane see you have to mix texture
and not
displacement i don't understand
um use chaos
node to avoid tiling dude i don't even
know what chaos note is
chaos node is that even in here
that's not even in here maybe it's a new
version of uh of octane or something
let's see let's see anyone have any
advice on this mixing situation
um let's see you can mix rgb and use
noise texture to blend them and use a
displacement
okay wait so you're saying
use a mix node and
do it with a mixed node
so it'd be like texture 1
texture 2 the amount
would be the same as this
noise
and that would go into a
let's see let's delete that
that would go into a displacement
0.5 4k
re-render the scene that's not really
working
huh i mean that's a good idea but i
don't know why it's not
working
yeah i'm not sure on that one
[Music]
well here's the here's a different way
to do it here's
here's a different way to go about it
let's go back to our original setup
let's pipe this stuff in to the
displacement of the original nodes here
and instead of using
the displacement or the mix material
we can actually have two ground planes
so one ground plane will be that let's
duplicate this ctrl drag
let's give this the other one so we have
two ground planes going and you can see
how we're kind of mixing between the two
let's set this ground plane
to cubic as well
and now you kind of have both chilling
up in here
and let's go with a third control drag
and let's give it this like rubble
this rubble texture we'll set that to
cubic as well
and the displacement or the tiling on
this one is insane
but to be very selective with it i think
what we can do is
we'll scale this down let's hop
out of here and let's go ahead and
yeah we'll scale it down which is not
going to help
our tiling situation but let's see if we
can't
adjust the displacement a little bit
more instead of 30 let's go to 15
and we'll rotate it
something like that and then let's go
ahead and actually give it
some extra displacement i'm gonna hold
shift
and let's throw a displacer node on it
and we'll set the shading to a noise map
we'll go up into the noise map
and let's simply just crank the
height
uh but let's see this is going off of uh
of actual geometry so let's just set
this to 10 by 10
and you can see how we get some like
rocky little lumps out of this thing
um maybe we can adjust a little bit more
so it's kind of square
10 by 20. but obviously these dirt
piles are too large for us and
they are a little bit uh a little chunky
so maybe we just take this to like
30 by 60. now it's really intense
so we're gonna have to bring down the
noise intensity
let's just do our global scale
we'll crank our global scale
there we go so it's a little bit more of
um we got some hills going on you know
let's go to the object we'll bring the
height back down
so it's very subtle
very very subtle like that which is
pretty cool
and let's take our
muddy texture our original muddy texture
let's bring it up by a centimeter
or 10.
oh that's not working i got to go to
object mode let's try it again
so this is a very you gotta play with it
you know
and this is a way for us to mix these
together i actually learned this from
david ariev
and that was his way of dealing with
tiling is to have multiple versions of
your foreground or background with
different displacement levels that kind
of pop in and out of each other like
that
and if your textures are close enough to
each other
you'll actually be able to get away with
uh
you know what am i trying to say if your
textures
are color corrected in a similar fashion
in this case dark glossy um
kind of desaturated then you can kind of
get away with it and how it blends into
each other
so yeah that's a nice fun little
little trick and if we hit play
we go back into our camera we can see
that we're you know we're getting a lot
of fun
[Music]
foreground variation as we
kind of scan and pan across
our foreground so i'm very very excited
for that that's going to be sweet
we just build it out you know we just
got to build this thing out
so i'm going to move our geometry let's
just move it a little closer to camera
and i'm gonna give it a touch of
uh depth of field so you gotta go easy
on this i'll show you guys about as far
as you can go
so let's go to thin lens
let's change it to 1 and we'll set
our focal point on our character
and this is going to be too much
that's going to be too much you can see
our background is kind of out of focus
foreground is kind of out of focus so
i'm probably going to take this to
two point eight maybe three three five
just
just like a little subtle something and
then i'm also going to change
the depth of field aperture to two
aperture edge to three and that gives it
an anamorphic feel it's gonna
kind of stretch out our bokeh highlights
into ovals and that's what you get when
you see an anamorphic lens
say on star wars or star trek or
something
any feature film really any any solid
feature film from the 90s
uh shot on film like they're gonna have
these oval
bokeh patterns in the lights when
they're in the foreground in the
background
that's because basically what the light
is looking through
is a well technically
yeah it kind of gets deep with it but
yeah it's camera stuff
it works
welcome back crow you've been gone for a
while but you have returned
light aaron d hey welcome first time
streaming for you dude thanks for
catching it
i hope it's a good time let's hope it's
a chill time for you
and we've done a good job we've kept a
thousand plus
viewers for the majority of the stream
here we're just hitting 950 right now
people are getting tired i understand
i'm getting a little tired myself that's
how it is
but man i can't wait to start adding
stuff to this
adding some burning barrels and
you know some pipes and wires and broken
crap and glass and bottles and
all that stuff that's when you have fun
but right now
i'm still blocking it out
we can do something cool back here too
we can even have this be a pit in the
ground a giant
massive hole in the ground or something
it could be pretty sweet
let's set up a z depth pass probably
going to need this
later we'll switch our renderer to
octane and we'll go to render
render pass check that info passes and z
depth pass
click that and we'll just adjust our
depth here
and we'll probably have to render i
don't know
probably just the one and we'll i'ma see
if i can do fog
in after effects like we did last time
because that's really gonna help on
render time
like a lot i think you can shift all
this stuff in after effects
sai shiran yo thank you again
for the generous super chat appreciate
you brother say recently i started
working on my
lighting skills how to improve this area
of cg pipeline because it's very
challenging sometimes
yeah man that's that's really the one is
lighting
it all comes down to lighting you can
have a really good render
really good environment but if it's not
lit well then
man that's that's a shame so let's
yeah definitely want to make sure your
stuff is lit as well as possible
for me what i do is i actually have
a list of
feature films at least a list of images
let's go to vfx materials
this would be pictures
cinematography here we go i have all
these movies
i hadn't updated this in a long time
but take the last samurai for example
i'm going through and i'm just finding
frames that i really enjoy and i'm
you know the frames that look nice that
make me go ooh that's a good one
you know and i'll ask myself well how is
it lit
if i'm trying to apply it because this
is this is what i would go back to when
i was working at rocket jump i'd pull up
these images and i'd say how is this lit
how am i going to make
you know our scene look like this and
at the time i was doing live action
shots you know i was
actually had a camera have my lights and
i have to set them up to make them look
like this and you just break it down you
see well there's definitely a light
coming back here from the window
so this is a nice little area and it's
hitting the edge here it's getting tom
cruise on the back here a nice little
edge light
um and it looks like that's kind of the
main light source you probably have a
fill light coming from over here
to hit him his face right here
but the majority of this is from this
light back here
and it's causing a nice little
silhouette and the way you get this uh
these light streaks is with a little bit
of atmosphere or some fog on set
you fog up your room a little bit and
it'll get you these light shafts
so i'll find frames that i really enjoy
or i want to ask myself how is this lit
like how would you light a giant scene
like this
well they got these giant windows over
here which is getting hitting everyone
from the side here
um you also have some lights hitting the
side of this train so you probably have
some lights coming from this side too
filling in all the you know the dark
side of people's faces you can see a
little edge there and that guy's neck
but it's mostly coming from these giant
windows
here's another good one tom cruise from
the window giant edge light and you
probably have
some sort of soft box in the foreground
you can look at
his eye light and you can see where the
lights are
and you can probably tell that there's a
camera right behind or there's a light
right behind camera lighting up his
sweat
this is doing a big one here and it's
getting his edge light there
so it's just an example of like
how you guys can find images that you
think look nice and just
think critically about them and break
them down
this is just lit from the sky
you know so this would just be an hdri
environment
to get you this look and obviously the
windows and the fire light
inside of all these little huts
same deal here they're probably spicing
it up with a bigger light
back here it's a giant movie set and
this is fake rain you know so they have
a big
probably soft box it's a blast in here
and getting you a little bit of that um
one thing is look where your shadows are
pointing which direction are your
shadows pointing
you know that's a good way to determine
um you know how your lights should be
set up
so yeah that's just a little trick for
you guys i think there's websites for
this now
i think there's like i don't know the
name of it maybe you guys have already
typed it into the comments but there's a
website
i forget the name of it but it basically
is this
i just did it the manual way because
that website wasn't really a thing when
i started doing it
yo this is one of my favorite ones
though this one's so good i love that
render
see it's that ground with the light back
here hitting the highlights on the wood
that's that's when you know what's up
see the shadows direction of the shadows
coming towards camera that means we have
a light up here somewhere
just out of frame lighting up
this here and probably these steps and
maybe even this
roof it's a big old light back there
it's a movie set they can do it
with the big budgets but we're in cg and
we get to do it for free
especially if you're using blender
all right all right
but another note on lighting y'all
another note in lighting is
my plan is to build out my scene
with this temp lighting that i have
right now
and when i get to a point where i have
like
most of my stuff kind of in the frame
then i'll start changing the light
and getting different looks to
think outside the box i don't want to
get pigeonholed into one look
um so i'll switch up the lighting
i'll do things that i normally wouldn't
do you know i'll position the sun in a
way i'll do a sunny version of the scene
i'll do a different i'll do a nighttime
version i'll do an overcast version i'll
do
a golden hour version i'll do a backlit
version i'll do a front lit version i'll
do
like a version with a red sky i'll just
do a bunch of different versions
and save those small little render
thumbnails and look at them and be like
what do i like about all these maybe i
can
it'll give you ideas start playing with
different colors blue and yellow
um you know cyan and uh
and what is it cyan and teal that kind
of movie film look
and the only way to come up with
different lighting solutions is to
experiment
so since we're in cg we can do it for
free experiment
light to your heart's content go crazy
with it you know
so that's definitely a good a good thing
to do
is switch up your lighting setup once
you got everything together it really
helps
you guys get out of your head outside
the box
and will spark some really interesting
results i i bet you
i bet you all cole i appreciate you man
thanks for hanging out with me um thanks
for working hard on
all your guys stuff uh it's been
freaking awesome yeah i i don't really
know where else to go from here
uh i mean i could start getting into it
but
i really need to start thinking
critically about how i'm placing all my
stuff
[Music]
um know i'd probably work a little bit
more
on the foreground
and get a little bit of variation in the
foreground maybe there's a part of the
foreground that has like
broken concrete tiles and stuff like
maybe let's bring in some of those
bridge assets that we've favorited so
let's go let's go to our favorites and
see what we can see here
oh the barrels man the barrels
definitely get some barrels up in here
that'll be fun screw it yeah let's get a
barrel
in here um what do you guys think
these rusted ones blue
green or red we got rusted barrels we
got blue
green or red i'm gonna leave it to y'all
what do you think i should throw in here
you guys wanna do a little color
contrast with some blue you wanna keep
everything uniform with the rusted
you wanna go green with it you wanna go
red with it what do you guys think
green red red barrels like half-life red
barrels red rusted
red barrels all rusted red red rusted
green red all right let's go with the
red let's go with the red
you guys are right rusted i mean the the
red barrel that's the explosive ones you
gotta watch out for those ones you know
um so let's download it
let's make sure we have this set to
export settings we want
not unreal engine we want c4d
i was gonna do this in unreal but y'all
i'd be out of my element a little bit
just a little bit too much
out of my element
all right well let's export the 4k
version
because we want to save as much computer
juice as possible
and y'all this is just the beginning i'm
probably going to throw in some rusted
barrels too
i'm going to throw them all in it's
going to be a good time but for now
we have a red a red barrel in our scene
i'm gonna rotate it so you can tell it's
like bent up a little bit
and let's adjust the let's see
let's right click it first we'll add it
to a new layer
and that new layer is called mega scans
and i want to change the material type
to glossy and
octane and for whatever reason
[Music]
that makes it look like a mirror
glossy
and beckman
defuse now universe let's try universal
again
i'll try changing these like see how
it's just like not really catching there
we go so when i change it to octane
the brdf model it really shines
which is what you want um glossy for
some reason
takes it to a
i think that's because the metallic is
turned on
um so if we take this
i like maybe it's universal
and metallic goes down to zero
ah it's because the albedo is plugged
into the metallic that would make sense
um
[Music]
let's try glossy again octane glossy
and try piping it in again
no that's not really working is it
because our index is set to 8 that's why
1.3
yeah so now we have we have control over
this barrel you know we can change this
barrel out however we want we can
control drag it
move it over
maybe have one like in the foreground or
something this definitely isn't final
it's just here as an asset
and it's not dirty enough
let's go with the rusted let's bring a
rusted one in let's see what that looks
like
rusted barrel we'll download the 8k but
we'll transfer over the 4k
again we're trying to save as much
computer juice as possible the scene is
going to get crazy
4k let's get our 4k going
export that 4k
and you got to be very particular about
the way you place
all of these objects
because the way your objects are placed
it shapes your scene
let's add this to our mega scans layer
and let's hop out of camera view
and try and get like the best look out
of this as possible
i want to make sure set this to octane
[Music]
glossy no that's not i guess glossy 1.3
yeah you see off the top it's all nice
and shiny that's exactly what we want
but we're not really seeing the tops of
these things unless of course
you know we angle it a little bit or
something
then you see the top of it just a bit
sticking out the ground
so we missed the super chat didn't we
naq montages
what up thank you for the super chat
says how much blood and gore
can um the submissions have are there
any restrictions on that yeah so that is
also
in the faqs on the discord so make sure
you guys are reading those
um blood and gore is okay
i'm cool with that just no nudity no
nudity in these things
um yeah simple answer simple question
good question but no it's in the faqs
check those faqs
[Music]
motion blur yes we want a little bit of
motion blur too
how we can do motion blur that's a great
question isn't it okay so
you can go to the motion blur little tab
here on your camera imager
i'll set this to 1 over 60 because you
the default baseline for motion blur on
film cameras any camera you're shooting
with is always
it's always double your shutter speed so
in this case our shutter speed or sorry
it's always double your frame rate
since our project frame rate is set to
30 frames per second
you want to um you want to set your
motion blur to 1 over 60
so it's double right
um and then you would check that on make
sure this is centered
save your scene turn it on and then
you'll have a little bit of motion blur
going
in your scene it's very subtle
but it adds it definitely adds it's all
about that realism you want to look as
real as possible
take away maybe the thin lens
so you just get the motion blur you see
the motion blur there
then it's happening more so in the
foreground
because the things in the foreground are
moving faster
versus the background now if you want to
get that saving private ryan look you
can set it to like
1 over 120 so it's a bit more of a
you have less motion blur in your scene
3.5 the high shutter speed look the
saving private ryan motion blur look
there's a higher shutter speed so one
over 120.
and since i kind of have a war scene you
know maybe that's the look i'm gonna go
for it probably is
very cool very cool so in my reference
you know there's a lot of stuff going on
in the ground
we have this bed frame we have the
barrels
um you know we have like
a bunch of rusted crap that's all over
the ground
there's a street here there's
cobblestone brick there's like stairs
that go up here
so i want to add all this stuff to the
scene
um burning barrels for sure yeah exactly
so i'll kind of be strategically placing
those throughout the week
and when i come back next week for the
stream hopefully my foreground is a
little bit more involved and it has a
lot more stuff going on that i can break
down for you guys and show you how
i've set that up um i'd love to wrap
out the foreground by next week that way
i can get going on the background
and then spend a week on the background
and then i'll spend a week
probably spicing it up with like
characters and robots and plants and
stuff
and then my last week will be in after
effects compositing the thing because
you know there's going to be a lot of
compositing going on for this
i want to try and do the fog
um in after effects like i did last time
maybe i'll do some rain
too that could be cool some wind i love
my
my atmosphere if you guys don't know
that by now i'm a big fan of atmosphere
i think it really adds to a render it's
stuff that is rare
in real life when have you seen a windy
foggy rainy scene that looks like this
never
when have you seen a scene that looks
like this not i don't know maybe once or
twice in your life
i know when we filmed the killzone live
action short on my uh
my youtube channel you guys i'm watching
on my youtube channel here
called a live action kill zone kill zone
extraction
we filmed in a place like this and it
was incredible
so incredible it was rainy and muddy and
my socks were coming off in my boots i
had so much mud stuck to my shoes oh my
god
we filmed for two days straight and we
had a pirate technician come out and
blow stuff up
so i'm a fan of that stuff man i'm a fan
of that weather a lot
all right so
i think i don't know i'm at a point
where i'm feeling pretty good um
i just need a crank on it you know
so i'll probably take this time here to
answer any questions you guys have
what's going on on with you all you guys
having a good day you guys having a good
uh
good stream session you guys having fun
with your renders i hope you are i know
i'm excited i'm getting excited it's
coming it's coming to life it is coming
together
so i'm very excited about that
all right tall goose jerry what app am i
using for my reference images i'm using
pure
ref pure ref it is a really nice one
um you can see it well
it's my whole head talking at this point
but it's pure f p u r e
r e f prf it's free and it's incredible
um great for organizing your references
and all that good stuff
where did i get the reference i made the
reference
i made it in photoshop um once this
stream is over
you guys can take a look at the
beginning of it where i go over
[Music]
my concept art how i made it i made it
in photoshop yeah
pieced it together from just a bunch of
reference images basically
um what else or how long have you been
doing
dc dc cinema 4d
um i've been in c4d for a while man like
i started in release 10 so that was
12 11 years ago i don't know
but i used 3ds max for six of those
years
i switched back so if you guys
hit me with the at punisher on the chat
it'll be a lot easier to
kind of focus on on these questions
um can you show the render so far in
full screen yes i can
yes i can let's do that
um let us
full screen mode
and we'll let this do its thing here
we'll let that render a little bit
um mr lindva it
asks do hey whoa hold on now it's don
allen
yo don allen in the house what's going
on dude you
are freaking the best man ever you guys
talk about my positive vibes
y'all haven't hung out with don allen
yet have you because this guy is the
most positive dude i know
um we spent like an hour just talking
about c4d plugins the other day it was
hilarious
um yeah don is great man if you guys are
into like
the whole um vr or ar
stuff uh don allen is your guy so check
out his channel
um i'll pin his comment here so you guys
can see
let's see uh um replace pinned
message yes yeah check out don allen
stuff he's a good
super good dude he worked at uh
dreamworks for a while but recently left
to do his own thing does that sound
familiar
um all right mr linva
do we have to make the render loopable
for extra points no you do not have to
make the render loopable because
all that's looping is the character
between all of these renders that's
what's looping you know
um your render doesn't have to loop you
can if you want it to but
it will not get you extra points um can
you crack open the unreal sequence scene
show us the sequencer quick i uh maybe
not
um that's gonna take some time to load
up
but josh hit me up on discord if you
have any questions about that man if you
if you need to if you have any dire
questions about
the unreal sequencer hit me up on
discord
going down the list taught jerry can you
look at your discord i sent you a cool
render i did
i will check it out after the stream um
i yeah tend not to want to have my
discord open while i live stream
for reasons yeah i just wanna i'd rather
keep people's privacy safe i don't know
what's on my discord too i don't want
you guys like
getting sam and nico's direct contact if
it's on there or something so i'm a
little just a little wary of opening
discord on the stream
i hope you guys uh understand
but i will check it out as soon as i as
we're done here
um do my do i make my own materials
i i have in the past
i don't really right now i make my own
surface imperfections
uh if you guys have been hanging out
with me for a while you probably know i
have a surface imperfection pack and a
video that breaks down how i made that
pack
but no i hadn't made my renders in a
while my own renders because
they're on mega scans and
i don't know they're on rd textures
maybe maybe i'll make a texture pack
there's just so many out there you know
[Music]
what else have i tried redshift yes i
have
a little bit i'm more of an octane boy
though
what should i practice get better at 3d
environment design and rendering marwan
good question
um follow environment artists on
instagram on artstation
on pinterest whatever um who make art
that inspire you
there's no way to to me the only way to
get good is to have good taste
you have to have good taste um
in in music if you want to be musician
you have to have good taste in art if
you want to be an artist
it's a good have good taste and
environment art if you want to be a good
environment artist
like find those artists and those images
and those environments that just blow
your mind
and use that as reference look at that
ask yourself how do they make this how
do they do this and start to craft your
own ideas go outside
start to take pictures of areas that you
think are cool um
like i love traveling i love going to
abandoned places
so that's kind of my inspiration too i
love art books
you know all these art books and stuff
this is how i get inspired
um i put on music you know that fits the
vibe
of uh you know that fits the vibe of the
art that i'm trying to make so i'm just
trying to surround myself
in the coolest vibes possible
and then from there i can start watching
tutorials and building up the the skill
set that will eventually get me to
create the art that i love
making right hopefully that makes sense
to y'all
um moving down the line here we got
questions we got questions
um do i take peeks in the whip channel
on discord absolutely
i definitely do i'm excited for what you
guys are doing
joel the walk sequence and character
object is broke
in c4dr21 any suggestions uh yes
two suggestions one if you're paying for
c4ds
um monthly thing just upgrade
your c4d you don't want to do that then
use the fbx the fbx should not be broken
you'll just have to apply the character
to the fbx i'm going to actually be
releasing a tutorial on how to do that
next week
so next week before i stream i'm putting
out a tutorial
on how to change out the character um
and how to adjust the arms and stuff
so look look out for that saturday 9 a.m
i'll put it out
and then i'll be streaming right after
that so i got you on that for sure
um
[Music]
yeah weird so it looks like any other
version of c4d
it's kind of broken well yeah use the
fbx you just test out that fbx guys
hopefully that works for you we got a
lot of questions
what are my pc specs they're on the
discord in the info
um info channel but i have an rtx
nvidia uh quadro 6000
i don't know i got some old cpu
um i i got two monitors
asus monitors um i got like
what 64 gigs of ram the specifics are in
the discord on the info but that's a
good question
and yo you know what no they're in the
description of this video
just realized i added that recently yeah
um how many products do you think i'll
be able to fit into the final video
how many final renders do you think i'll
be able to fit in the final video
there's 125 last time
we'll see man we'll see we'll see how
much music we can get written for it
um and we'll see how long it really is
gonna be and then we'll go from there
all right we'll make the best choice
can i use real image projection like ian
hubert
in my render um yeah sure go for it
absolutely is it okay to do the
challenge even if we don't have that
much skill absolutely
you want to learn you want to grow
through this this is this is a
challenge for you guys challenge
yourself get better with this all right
you should definitely be doing this if
if you feel like you're not good enough
that's a bunch of crap all right we had
people who just started blender
on the last challenge and they submitted
stuff and it was in the it was in the
montage it was freaking awesome
how long did it take me to settle on a
concept um
[Music]
i didn't know what i was gonna do until
friday i basically used um
i sat down and for
a couple hours i went through all my art
books and i listened to some ambient
music
and i just started getting ideas and um
wacom actually sent me
this freaking awesome mobile
workstation this thing's crazy so it's
basically a computer
as a tablet that you can draw on so i
used this
um and i booted up photoshop and i
started putting together some like
rough reference scenes
um and just yeah just started building
it out you know
it took me a couple hours to figure out
what i wanted to do but it was dedicated
time
that i spent you know trying to trying
to get that going
what else here will my render make it to
the final montage it's pretty bad but
i'm doing my best
um my goal is to include all the renders
in the final montage
um off topic but you ever consider
making a full course on gumroad or
something like 10 12 hours of stuff in
one course yes i have
that is my goal for the end of this year
or the beginning of next year is to make
a full-on course
for you guys it'd be like a paid course
or something um
that's just like click by click
everything you guys need to know
on how to do all the stuff um
so yeah keep an eye out for that
how many products do you think would be
able to fit we answered that one let's
see where do we post
works in progress for this on the
discord
larry it's on the discord um
let's see what else we got a lot of
questions still coming in how are my
planning
to make destructions on buildings assets
y'all
assets i'm gonna go and just buy some
assets on cgtrader
it would take me 20 years and a day to
be able to build all these buildings
manually so i'm going to use the assets
that i have
um and make that happen absolutely
um what else do i have any advice on how
to keep that visual weight
and not bog the whole thing down slash
ruin it by adding all those cool details
from your ideas
we're not sure how to fill empty space
hey that's a good question yeah how do i
how much is too much that's a good
question how much is too much
well that kind of comes down to
personal opinion
you know we are talking about art here
um if you
look again going back to reference if
you look at renders
that blow your mind from other artists
ask yourself how they compose the image
to get the effect that that you're
looking at
um for instance let's take a look
at some of these movie frames
uh children of men so this frame here
is framed very nicely actually there's a
lot going on but it's framed very nicely
what i'm seeing is two little blocks
of space that are being taken up here
and here
the fog adds depth to your image
and then you also have a little bit of
sky coming in so it's brighter up top
it's getting darker down towards the
bottom
you have this little swoop right here
that kind of draws the eye
my eye starts kind of here because the
characters are actually moving through
the scene coming towards
the camera and then you have this giant
swoop here which guides the eye
right around in this little area um and
then you have these little details off
to the left off to the right
that frame the image they frame the
center point of what's going on so you
have
all these little things like this little
rusted pipes
thing here um that really helped bring
out the environment
now the the the color of these buildings
are bluish kind of cyan green
compared to the ground which is a little
bit more brown it's a bit warmer
so you have these nice color nice subtle
color contrast going on between the
buildings and the ground
so it helps these pop out a little bit
more this also is kind of like in a
bluish hue compared to the buildings
so that pops out a little bit too let's
take another
look here actually this one is a great
example it's a center silhouette
image here and the reason this works so
well is because
two things one is center framed it's
symmetrical
and also you have a really bright um
focus this is your highlight this is
your focus of the scene
and then everything else kind of falls
off onto the side if you were to add a
bunch of crap
in this hallway it would distract the
eye from the center point
of the frame here they did just enough
they added just enough crap
on the corners of this thing and keep in
mind guys these are movies
they don't just find these locations
they build these locations from scratch
so they added all this stuff by hand
they artistically placed all this stuff
specifically to guide the eye to the
center point of the screen
and yeah it'd be too much if you had a
bunch of crap in here of like bicycles
and
cupboards and you know pipes and
everything like no it's
focus is here it makes it easy on the
viewer this one here is not that great
of an example because it's a moving shot
it's a big old moving shot that i just
cut a little piece from
but this is a good this is a great frame
this is a really nice one
um you have clive owen as the main
character
and he's looking through this window
this busted out window of a bus that
he's on
and you're seeing what's the brightest
point it's the sky obviously
and the reflection off the side of this
building so you're looking to the
brightest point of the image
which is where our main character is
looking
and you know you have a lot of movement
back here in the movie
you know you have your your smoke that's
moving you have your people that are
moving around and stuff and this image
eventually turns into this image here
the camera pans with these characters
that start running
and they get shot down as they run past
um
so what would make this too much if
there was a bunch of crap here in the
way
you have these guiding lines that are
focusing the eye to the center point the
focus of your
of your shot here you know what i mean
and if this was full of a bunch of stuff
you wouldn't really be sure what to look
at
so they're guiding the eye with value
these these
bright tones and the dark tones
naturally looking at the brighter stuff
and at the movement
all right so if we were to take that and
apply that to our render here
then we're going to be looking naturally
at the brightest point of the image
based off of my my concept art
here the brightest point of the image is
definitely the sky
and to be honest with you i feel like
it's
imbalanced we're looking up here and
this is too dark
so what i'm going to need to do is
balance out the
focal point of my image a little bit
more it's too bright on one side and too
dark on one
on the other side it almost looks like
two images cut right down the middle
and i want to blend the foreground the
background the left side the right side
all together to make it feel like it's
part of
one world and i also need to be
very specific about my values here
the sphere i need to maintain the
spherical shape
but i also don't want to forget about
all the dark side over here i need to
bring like some
i'll probably bring in some uh orange
light some fire light here
i might actually cut out a little alley
way from here to have another
like focal point maybe chop off a little
bit of this
um and maybe the character will be a
little bit brighter or maybe it'll be
darker against silhouette and i'll have
the background back here
have a lot of fog kind of in this area
and it will actually help bring the
character out from the environment so
you you you know kind of focus on the
character
by framing them with stuff so you see
how this little bed frame
is is like it's kind of in a weird place
to be honest honestly i would flip this
around and have it
loop back this way this way it kind of
like cradles
and frames our main character so the
the way i'm placing all my little
objects and stuff
all the little detail it's going to be
to frame
my main character i'll have stuff on the
edges of the frame
on the like right in the foreground and
kind of off to the side too now our
camera is moving
so that frame is going to adjust so i'm
going to have to be very
specific about how i do that and it's
going to be a lot of
a lot of trial and error that i'll be
able to show you guys
next week hopefully i'll have a lot more
done on the foreground to be in a near
near final on the foreground next week
and break that down for you guys so
yeah i'm excited about that that was a
long long-winded answer wasn't it
all right you guys doing all right
i think i think i'm gonna call it you
know we're at three hours now
i'm feeling good about my foreground my
template foreground
i'm gonna start going in here and just
placing a bunch of objects and feeling
it out so
um i appreciate you all for hanging out
with me uh i guess i answer a couple
more questions before i leave
oh don allen's getting some love i love
it i love it
broken is it within the rules to use
after effects and element 3d to create
the shot for this challenge
of course it's within the rules yeah man
the faqs if you read the faqs it says
that you can use any program it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter i just want you guys
to create learn and grow that's it
have i been to film school no i have not
been to film school
i went to a tech school for a year and a
half i dropped out after a year and a
half
i was taking after effects classes and
cinema 4d classes but to be honest with
you guys
some of you already know this i knew all
that stuff already because i was
watching
um cgtutts.com and i was especially
watching videocopilot.net and i learned
all that stuff in my free time
and i was you know bummed out that i
wasn't learning a lot
and my teacher my after effects teacher
mr mason let me work on my stuff
my youtube stuff as a grade in my after
effects class because he knew he
i i knew everything already not
everything but i knew
you know the basics it was a beginner
class
and he was actually the teacher who
convinced my dad to let me drop out of
college and move out to
california to work with freddie so shout
out to mr mason
i'll never forget you
any other questions y'all
hmm what will my character be dragging
um i don't know
maybe a giant pack of capri sun
i don't know a box of plants
it's planting plants as it moves
throughout this robot i
think it'll be like some sort of cyborg
robot thing
um so i don't know yet we'll see
and we'll have to see
do you take music submissions you mean
in your render or just
i don't know i'll be cutting out all the
audio from your render
even the sound design if you do it
because i'm going to be adding my own
music
over top
ggs mr mason absolutely
how's my movie coming along
tenem you're working on your next one
already that's awesome dude i didn't
know you did
a movie um maybe i knew that but
you're doing your next one that's great
yeah my movie's coming along good um
the writer i'm working with nate davis
he uh
the dude's friggin incredible very
talented writer
we figured out our characters we figured
out our story and he's doing an outline
right now so
i'm excited to read the outline and
we'll go over it and we'll do notes and
we'll figure it out but
yeah it's turning out to be really cool
it's gonna be an adventurous
um action mysterious drama
comedy it's gonna be everything it's
gonna have all the good stuff it's gonna
be adventurous it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be scary it's gonna be full
of a lot of good stuff so i hope you
guys enjoy this movie
in a couple years when it comes out
that's that's the long run right there
man that's the long game for sure
but it's gonna be sweet
can the character not be dragging
something sure the character cannot be
dragging something
but let me ask you this why is the
character leaning forward
why is the character leaning forward is
it carrying a really heavy backpack
is it dragging something maybe you move
the arms is it pushing something
who knows is it really windy is it
leaning into the wind
who knows that's up to you to decide
why is the character leaning forward um
and if you guys don't know
this is kind of confusing but the
overall note is no you cannot change the
character's
body animation you cannot touch it
except
the shoulders down to the fingers you
can move the arms
but don't touch the head don't touch the
torso don't touch the legs don't touch
the freaking hips don't touch the
shoulders
i'm sorry i said you can do the
shoulders basically the arms you can
adjust the arms
so if you want your character pushing
something they can be pushing something
if you want your character shielding
something
shielding your face or something that's
cool too so
you can adjust the arms but that's it
don't touch anything else
but y'all i think that's about it i
think i'm gonna call it i'm gonna get
some lunch i'm gonna hang out with cliff
or maybe get some drumming in get some
one wheeling in
but y'all thank you guys for hanging out
with me anything that you guys need to
know let's see
um make sure you read the faqs
please read the faqs don't make it more
complicated on yourself
um some pretty simple answers in there
for y'all
trying to keep it as simple as possible
follow me on
instagram i mean all the stuff's in the
description you know the twitter the
instagram
all that stuff it's in the description
um
what else what else yeah next week i got
a standalone video for you and a live
stream
so i'm gonna show you guys how to
replace the character in c4d and how to
move the arms and stuff
and then hopefully we'll be finishing up
the foreground
what else what else um
i will have a submission link for you
this week but don't get eager to submit
all right
make sure you guys spend the time you
need to take
take till june 1st make it good add the
details all right
because those details are really going
to come a long way and make your render
better simply it's going to make it
render better keep filling it out keep
making it nice keep iterating on it
change the lighting
find the best version of what you're
working on okay and submit that don't
submit anything else
um yeah
i think that's it don allen
thanks for stopping by man um
i'm wondering are you gonna do something
for the for the challenge
it'd be sweet it'd be really cool if you
did man
um but i understand if you're busy then
you got your thing to do too you know
we're all running these youtube channels
and it's tough
being our own boss it's very busy a lot
of work
a lot of work but uh y'all thank you so
much
thanks for hanging out with me no art
review today
no art review next week but you know
maybe what i will do is review some
works in progress next week
so keep posting to the works in progress
um
channel on the discord i'll pull some of
them and i'll tell you guys what i like
about them what i think hey keep going
in this direction
maybe i'll give you some examples of uh
some works in progress that
are blocking this the sphere element too
much i'm not gonna rag on you i'm just
gonna let you know hey maybe
work the sphere in a little bit more you
know what i mean maybe maybe uh
work the character in a little bit more
so hopefully that'll help you guys kind
of guide your renders
to a more unified place um
[Music]
sweet don allen's working on one he's
gonna have raptors in it heck yeah
dude i'm so excited yes yes yes yes
sweet um so many questions guys i'll
have to get them next time
do i have any tips on starting a youtube
channel revolving around 3d
yeah consistently post consistently post
every week
it's a lot of work but consistency is
the only way
and make sure your thumbnail is good
because your thumbnail is the only thing
that is
keeping the viewer from clicking on your
video
all right so remember that i learned
that from from nico corridor
all right y'all have fun
have a good one i'll see you on the
discord this week i'm gonna hop into
that voice channel
i know you guys are working and you're
working in the voice chat that's awesome
it's really cool to see
um the myself and the mods are talking
about it in our mod chat we're like yo
look at the freaking voice channels are
popping off so i'll pop in from time to
time this week guys
but y'all have a good one thank you for
everything
um hit that skillshare link down below
please it helps me out
it really does um helps me do more of
these streams and stay alive
so sign up and learn something it's a
win-win for both of us all right
we all are amazing thank you so much for
your time i'm excited to see your stuff
and i'll be
seeing y'all soon all right so i'm gonna
hit you with this end screen
nice little track for y'all i'll see you
soon peace out guys later
[Music]
two
[Music]
you